all right finally yeah man I thought I
planned correctly but clearly I did that
the apologies on the wait everybody
flash point it bounces what is going on
besides me being late you know
normal morning so far I got my workout
in and just was like what do you been up
to and then I'll get to mind just just
battling man sleep deprivation
that's the word shake it out it's just
been dude I've been playing nothing but
this game I just can't stop and I had to
literally put myself on timeout um
actually the last two days and just say
look you've got to rest thank you
I'm averaging four to five hours of
sleep this is not good that's it let me
just shut it down a little bit and you
know just kind of take care of myself a
little bit better and then get to it the
game's not going anywhere cuz because
what's what's happening is that there's
so much content and I'm trying to stay
ahead stay ahead stay ahead I'm okay
ready for the raid and then BAM
shattered drone comes out and I'm like
you kidding me and then like we
attempted it and I was you know I was
deal decent but like that's something I
had to do so I couldn't stay for whole
thing and it's just this constant just
when you think you've got things under
control content wise because we all know
how the powerful gear drops go everybody
said hit your whole map is littered with
things to do alright so yeah it's just
been this constant struggle be trying to
stay ahead of the game and I'm hardcore
putting in the hours and I can't keep up
and I see the taxi had an article like
that and I completely empathize with it
like the it it's a good thing like it's
just so much to do you know what the
completion is in me is I must stay ahead
I must stay here but I said you know
what
falling back taking care of yourself
I'll get to it when I get to it yeah I
gotta take a little breather in there
occasionally sometimes but
not long but thank you guys for joining
us in chat this morning yes and for me I
had an insane weekend okay and I wanted
to give a shout out to pretty much 50%
of my my youtube channel
I haven't knew I have 50% more
subscribers than I did literally last
week for checking out the channel I was
like hey you know I do need to I want to
do this guide again I want to do it
without whisper cuz I had a few requests
YouTube gods shined on my video and got
out there in the world and yeah I got
some yeah I was like okay so you know
just barely cracked 8000 subs with the
giveaway cool to sit there's like a
working towards 10 I'll eventually get
there and then all of a sudden the video
started going nuts and started climbing
and I'm gonna have this video view that
ever in my life of YouTube and it's just
like it got shined on so I just want to
shout out to all of the new people who
are following my channel thank you guys
the comments were awesome the support
it's been amazing and the legs on that
video have been a much longer than I
expected myself and have been all week
because I've just been watching this
thing go nuts
and I guess it's just one of those
pieces where you know right place right
time and I'm glad you guys enjoyed the
video so welcome to my world and welcome
to this world of Flashpoint with cogito
the man of the best interest in the
business thank you seriously everyone
you can just listen the first 10 minutes
of every iron Lords podcast and you'll
just laugh all the people the guests
whoever's in there I'm sure there's one
or two of me that I are completely
unjustified I mean you know we know our
history we go back and first off
congratulations because I know how hard
you work and me and you talk offline a
lot and just to see your journey and
like I said you know even meeting at
Guardian con what is it been out two
years now it's been to feel free I don't
know long time ain't no you know I just
seen you you had the passion yeah look
this guy's ready to make content he's
ready to deliver you know quality stuff
and he's just knowledgeable just to see
your journey continue is something that
is just really outstanding to me I don't
think you get enough credit and I tried
to champion you as much as possible when
I saw that whisper video I'm like oh he
got one
he got away like that it was so good to
see and like I call him affectionately
the Bob Ross of this this guy what you
know what the strengths that you have
with your guys in just the way you do
your content is that you break it down
so that a layman can understand that no
one is overwhelmed and I even used it
when cuz one thing about that I'm glad
you did it for that one because as a
warlock
I have jumping nightmares a lot of
floaty people they're like this feels
wrong yeah the flues mast is like the
worst thing you can do the wall I can
say hey jumping puzzle yeah time limit
right
so is it cancel that section encapsulate
all my fears as a wall out everyone's
ahead of you you jump in slow and you're
like nope
take your time go here you can jump here
you can do this okay take like you just
have that style that's just very calm
out all right I bought it he got he got
follow this do this and sure enough bull
and now you got the solo you know
whispering going on so super super
Congrats
well deserved please if you have not
subscribed to be brontosaur ready
what is launching top guys in the game
and please support this guy and like I
said we always try to link up and do
this fast plane things y'all and it is a
privilege so once again salute Lord it
boxes well thank you very much so that
yeah I just couldn't have blown me away
it's not like I mean there's people who
get views like I got on my videos they
get them in like an hour to put them up
but for me I don't see anything like
this so it's at 189 thousand views right
now and it's just thank you it's been
amazing and I'm just beside myself and
it's just kind of one of those things I
kind of just blown away yeah I'm over 12
I was like worried about like hey I just
broke 8,000
you know a couple extra hundred I'm over
12,500 down just like holy crap so thank
you par five thank you everybody out
there in chat so any and all the words
and love that you guys spread so much
appreciated and just one of those things
I'm like yeah if you could see if I had
a face right now on camera guys the the
world of destiny to is one of the
reasons that's even possible is because
this game is in such a great place right
now and as you said we cannot stop
playing it is really like it's one of
those pieces but honestly it's hard to
make more than one character I saw a
tweet I think it's like always destiny
read it post in there little pieces up
it's like your main character is your
main and that's it if you're really
gonna stick with one right now much less
trying to do all three I mean you got a
life it four three just to try and be
really out there and some of the crazy
people up there who sit hit 600 already
I'm just like I'm happy I just broke 550
and I've been playing a lot and some of
that like rolls and pieces like that but
there's always so much to do you log in
a li to do am I gonna work on this
character so I'll work through five
crucible matches and three gambit
matches doing a grind for malfeasance
now which is an option just out there
you haven't even seen that boss yet am I
gonna do the daily stories and we're
gonna do the strikes am I gonna work on
a nightfall with some friends and kind
of pick my way through that one Dreaming
city do I want to do blind well oh I can
get my new seed of life from my third
subclass this time it's just like it
doesn't stop and now shattered through I
haven't even touched that thing yet I'm
I'm barely cracking 550 curl let me tell
you it I'm an amazing near at least 5 75
70 80 80 will get into it but all I will
say before we get into it is that is
that this new thing that they're doing
is definitely in my opinion like a three
for a three man version of a raid they
they finally finally done something
that's the equivalent that you can do
with a fireteam and we'll get into it
some more but man kudos to them this
thing
yeah and it's tough there it's at least
the enemies you never saying once you
get there you know saying but we did I
did attempt it and from what I've seen I
was very pleased and a shout out I gotta
give one thing though I don't think that
forsake is gonna
of credit these strikes these you know
this done genuine here like all the new
strikes post Riven the raid last which
rate the ambiance it's amazing like like
wow like whoever was designing this it
is especially anything that involves a
sentient ascendant plane mm-hmm really
looks spectacular there was one mission
I don't know which one it was I was
doing and like we were doing like a mini
jump thing and it's like it feels like
you in a Senate plane between space and
there's boulders going past you and you
ascendant challenges it this week that's
really crazy
I didn't do this week's but it's but
what's this week tell me what's this
week's this week is you come in and
there's a lot of jumping to the middle
platform you kind of kill the ads you
pick up a store and then you have to
smash the nights and then take the sword
out so that's this one but there's like
there if you just go wander around that
place before you even attack the enemies
there are so many different platforms
and directions to go wander on in there
I got ya little like flickers a picture
like lightning in the background a
picture a strobe that goes off like once
every 20 seconds and if you glance right
or wrong you might catch an entire like
array of platforms that you can go
wander off and you're like oh let's go
see it's like yeah so you can just get
lost in some of these descending
challenges which is really cool last
week was the platforming like going
straight up and this one was like all
about like the big hive sword yes in
challenges have actually been noticeably
different saying yes
spider babies each one of those so
they're kind of annoying sometimes but
they don't have their own mechanics to
them so soloing each of those is kind of
its own thing yeah absolutely a great
man and again shout out to these post
story rage strikes and it's just so good
and I can't remember the name it was me
and addict getting shout to gaming at it
we I did it and it was just a phenomenal
you haven't seen nothing yet wait till
you do this I think we had to light
uncorrupt
Kali or one of the other how you
pronounce it detentions I can't
pronounce it right yeah yeah whatever
one of them was still corrupted in this
mission involved going into cinema
everything about the corrupted strike
where you go back and forth you miss
yeah yeah yeah that's the strike that
unlocked after all right that thing
looks you go like halfway through you're
like oh this looks like The Dreaming
City and then you go through like one
section you're like whoa hold on and it
just opens wide up into kind of like
this picture to be like the edges of the
reef and you're kind of on the tips of
space and you're like what is happening
right now it's just like and look and be
like damn yeah that that's the vibe
that's the feel and again they don't get
enough credit I mean this content is
spectacular man I'm just really enjoying
myself and yeah we got a lot to talk
about what we could talk about David I
keep going around those if you if you
haven't just jumped in the corrupt it's
like randomly or it hasn't come up on
your list of things that just like pop
through just go matchmaking to it and go
see it it's really cool and even just
the mechanic in there when you pick up
the charge you can throw it back and
forth to hit or harder yes little pieces
like that so I mean it's yeah there's
just the little additions but just the
look of the game and there's a lot of
people talking abouts like I definitely
want to play anthem I'm curious to see
how it is and it looks really cool but
it was like there's no way you can say
dusting to looks bad and honestly if
you're playing on PC it's like it's
you'll never go back so can't wait for
you to join me in that party but there's
a lot of people out there talking about
cross save which gave us hope one day D
I'm thinking D 3 d 3 definitely yeah I'd
be nice just to be able to like be like
hey somebody wants help on plate I got
all these requests all the time it's
like and I can't keep up six characters
anymore I'm just working on PC to try
keep up three but somebody's just even
comments on whisper be like hey could
you run me through I'd love to run
people through on PlayStation facts I
mean granted my skills with control or
maybe janky right now for a while but
either way it's like I'd love to jump on
and help them with what I have but I was
like just because I've put in the time
and it's so bad to split between all
that stuff so well yeah so we're gonna
talk about this week at Bungie a couple
other pieces one of them was mentioned
that we're kind of the topics and then
we'll kind of delve in a bit more
this whole dreaming city stuff that
we've kind of already touched on halfway
but we will jump into that one here so
over here on the club you guys can see
basically the ascendant challenge up
here is the top kind of graphic I always
like the picture it's really cool to see
a bow on the back too is honestly like
the bows still keep being pretty solid
I like how they just the way they hit I
mean PvP they're not as viable as I wish
they were them and they are but you
can't like you know get a couple three
shots on a pulsed rifle and kill
somebody before they go hide if you tap
them with a bow they have a chance to go
hide but you know if you're working
around comboing those people and stuff
like that they just feel good but in pvp
and PVE i love that i can just basically
have a slow sniper rifle with like sixty
bullets yeah without really cool really
cool I didn't realize how effective bows
would be in this expansion they've
really shown that they've kind of got
their own place no matter it's really
good to see ya it's nice just a few and
it's one of those things if you're going
through even if it's just something you
need to pop a shield I've got my subtle
calamity the void one I got it with
explosive head and dragon fly works real
well nice yeah that's a fairly solid
combo there's only boughs I will say
which I'm okay with they don't need to
have completely trashed rolls yeah but
there's only seem to be a small variety
of roles like arsenic bite always seems
to be the same yeah awesome yeah so
there's not a ton of choices on those
but yeah if you guys haven't seen we'll
just start with the Dreaming city so if
you guys haven't checked it out and
you're wondering how this all works by
the way and go check out my name is Bai
if his video over the lore of The
Dreaming City and everything that's
going on
it explains this three-week cycle and he
does it very well so this is gonna be
the reason why or on a three week cycle
why some of the stuff comes up once
every three weeks why there's this like
you know continuous cycle of things that
are stuck in so what we've got is we
finished the raid and then of the
Dreaming city was on a three week cycle
so this is the third week so if you've
wondered around the Dreaming city when
you logged in the first time to the
Dreaming city how did that look by the
way man it looks fantastic because I um
we logged in unlike you just sees like
what it reminds me of Oh
you know like Venom's sin by a constant
yeah and he's like when it's in little
bits dropping from the sky I'm like what
is going on so that's when I read okay
let and then you just see all the arm
looked like what you call taking orbs
and stuff like that and you see the
manifestation of all these you know it
just seems the city's corrupted the cast
was all he said the church's corrupted
and it just looks aesthetically very
cool and I'm just like yo this game just
you know every week man it's just like
it just continues to do something new
and continues to add something new and
they did say this but to actually see it
in effect and and just done so well and
the fact that they visibly changed the
atmosphere of the Dreaming city and you
know the whole explaining the whole
cycle and all that stuff it's just
really cool man I thought that was a
fantastic touch again kudos to Bungie
man can't get enough this they just
knocking it out the park with this
expansion and keep doing things but yeah
I was very very much impressed seriously
like I don't envy whatever comes next I
know like some of the annual passes
probably for whatever and those are
gonna be smaller pieces we know for sure
grade layers here and there at which a
means I'll be very curious about the red
layers because this time they'll
probably have a story component to them
so black army already no I'm not saying
arresting police back on I'm saying rest
in peace like dusty whatever or next
September whatever the big one is all I
can say is this September set the bar
high so they gotta work like literally
overtime for the next 12 months to try
and keep up with what they've done on
this one it has been amazing the
dreaming city the tangled Shore the
bounties the progression and all those
pieces it's just like it's just
constantly stuff to do and not everybody
has the same opinion we'll get into some
of that stuff later as difficulty and
leveling and stuff like that but just
the amount of things we have to do in
just the progression they promised on
and delivered yeah damn lay yeah
absolutely
but if you guys seen it or you're not up
high enough to even try it or you're
just living under a rock the shattered
Throne is a new piece now we've had
strikes before do you literally go from
point A to point B you'll have a boss in
the end there might be some minor things
to him where he's like oh I'm gonna do
some shield and you got it you know
a couple enemies we have something now
called a dungeon if you have a real
world or an MMO these are what strikes
which these are what strikes could have
been and these are probably more to the
level of the dungeons right word it is a
true experience with mechanics multiple
bosses multiple pieces to it and it's
towards an in-game piece and this is the
type of thing that honestly I know lower
it may be a harder thing this time to
make it work but this is the type of
piece where if they because strikes
still I feel like need a place because
outside of having to do my weeklies for
them there's no real narrative reason
there's no real purpose and progression
that makes you actually have to go you
don't go through the story then you go
do some public events and some grinding
and then you know strikes will get you
from say like 520 to 540 if you know
strikes are doing that you would grind
them out for a little while or I is that
piece of your progression right now
they're kind of a piece but this dungeon
is really really cool
from what I've seen and I have not tried
to spoil too much it will kick your butt
yeah mechanics to it which is really
cool so it's like a mini raid basically
but it's a 3-man so you don't have to go
find a big group you're gonna need a
couple friends to do it
I mean you but there's also a challenge
to solo it so that you actually intend
for that to be a thing and whatever the
hell I get high enough level I'll go try
and catch up to esoteric and do it I put
that in there it is three-man that they
said okay we are gonna make this so
lovable and there's a challenge to
follow solo it so Wow there's up there
pretty high so esoteric has already done
it shout-out to that man yes he's he's
amazing he's yeah he's crazy but at some
point I'll join you guys and probably do
my Bob Ross commentary a long time ago
too as a comment nose just like
somebody's like you know you're like the
Bob Ross of this new videos and I about
fell out of my chair when that like
anybody watch if you've not wisely buzz
it is the most like you get the stress
out of a person you just say very cool
you could be the most intensity that's
when I saw you in the arm back in the
challenge the elders know that's what
you do you take your lock you do you had
nothing manacles it was very calm very
precise very delivered
and just explaining it for the layman so
there he comes and he said you know what
I may have a chance to do it this was
like I'm not like the epic tear but I
was like there's points where I've gone
through things enough I'll learn the
fights enough and that's what like I
spent more time on d1 so like nightfall
so those with the shield brothers I can
tell you be like okay it's about a
hundred eighty thousand damage when you
move the dude out of the room and that
was one I think pyro even noticed he's
like so much detail in here and it was
just those little pieces that I try and
give that will help and same thing with
the shattered throne it's like they're
gonna be certain mechanics you got to go
through and it's like yep you'll have
like an hour video of my commentary so
hopefully my voice doesn't bother you I
got one other comment once those like
this is kind of like ASMR it was like
please don't let me put you to sleep
while you're playing but honestly share
the throne looks really really cool and
I just like it's like just when we think
we've got the raid and this is the end
of it there's a whole other thing in
here and I'm just like how do you keep
throwing stuff at us Bungie I don't have
enough time to do all of this crap it's
gonna be gone for three weeks too so
that's the other piece I kind of wanted
to get your thoughts on that what do you
think about this whole three week cycle
so you've got the wish in Turbo you've
got the shattered throne these couple
pieces that are now basically cycle do
you agree do you wish it was always
staying there what are your thoughts
surprisingly I don't have a problem with
funnies I'm actually I might actually
miss out on getting wishing it's
depending on my schedule too so I'm not
gonna touch it this time yeah so I'm
probably not and you know what it's okay
it's okay I mean it's gonna be there
kind of reminds me of sleeper in d1 when
sleeper only came around I believe one
part of that quest the first part or
ever to kick it off came around like on
the seventh of the month or something to
that effect if I call and listen I think
it's a cool Easter egg thing that goes
in conjunction with story I have no
problem with that
you know I get it for the people who you
know they're out of town this week or
whatever you know they have
responsibilities
you know shadows as well be afraid my
belly you gotta watch 12 5 to check
those guys it was a sink
and I know that was the whole purpose
of it but there's part of me that was
like I couldn't because part of me was
like I think he was actually kind of a
little annoyed that he didn't get there
but I was also like he kept harping on
it so much and I was like I know you
play devil's advocate but to a point of
almost annoyance for me and as I know
that was kind of the job what he was
doing I literally do it was like I know
cuz I literally read the tweet and him
and we're going back and forth is like
anywhere and that's totally fine but I'm
just sitting there playing from my
perspective I was like I literally did
not touch the raid I grinded in these
new hours I didn't have the thing in
there but I knew I wasn't ready and I
had absolutely zero problem not being
first I was like a whole devil's
advocate piece of just like Abe you care
that we're only two teams that finished
it I was like no because I come from a
different background exactly like I mean
when I played World of Warcraft and I
was going through literally just the
initial expansion before I even I got
into molten core and I don't even think
that was the big raid that was out but
it was just the guild that I joined
right and cores this okay picture at in
boss raid and like picture ours but also
picture the fact that you have to kill
the first boss over and over and you
only get to kill him once a week and
that whatever drops you get from that
not every person gets an upgrade
come have to do that over and over per
week just to progress to the next boss
you know that's a little progress then
you come into this and I'm like okay so
I missed the first week whoa yeah no
circuit to you no no no no I hate you
I'm with you I'm literally with you I
mean like I said listen to no more
shadows guys you know I feel from you
know saying don't get me wrong I feel
from cuz there's something to be said
okay yeah you know you want to be part
of that that whole thing and you know
your light level and you know you're
grinding you felt you're grounded your
hardest off because I had the same
problem we felt he crying the hardest he
could possibly do with the time he had
and he still wasn't enough and like you
said and like I think uh you know
something again some of these guys said
to as well like hey it's still gonna be
there
you don't saying so really what is the
issue the issue is not about that it's
not badly designed and you know bungees
you know not making it fair it's just a
matter of look if you have the time yes
you're able to put in the work yes you
can get there obviously it's an insane
amount of grind that you got to do it
but at the same time if you don't get
there it's okay and we talked about this
last flash
it's okay so this really comes down to
just an emotional thing because that
person wants to be part of the world's
first crew let's just keep it real what
it is right like it's an emotional thing
it's like I want to do it on first day
with these other guys you know I'm
saying but you can't and that's okay
listen I got we beat Kelly we're up to
Shiraki we're doing it and my ray crew
is doing it at a nice pace we're like
okay we can get this done if we have
flawless runs but it's okay we'll come
back well level up stronger and then
we'll knock out that then we'll get to
the ochre you'll see it's gonna get done
the issue just comes down to the eagle
and then like like I said when you put
belts and you put
if you put you know bungee saying your
name I like this direction I like the
fact that the content is have you have
to grind your level to get up to certain
parts I like that I really you know it's
not in my opinion artificially extending
anything to me it's already hard right
if you have flawless execution you can
do it so listening to those guys you
know I definitely have that you know
this I was come let's be real I mean
everybody was disagreeing Frank really
as far as foreign team chat was dessert
for the sake of argument you know at
this point with no less than a certain
amount of people whatever whatever you
know did it is this what they want and I
think honestly they're okay with that I
think one she's fine with that it's been
I mean you go too far the other
direction it's a point of a raid it's
like you want this thing to be an
extended process and things like that
and they're working toward these epic
things I mean they had viewer like that
I had 30 to 50,000 view he had 30 up
like three o'clock in the morning yeah
we had like 50,000 viewers for like 18
hours long I mean that's insane but
people wanted that and that's why
struggle that worked through if it would
have been a lower level or easily
accessible and there were more people
involved in the race and things like
that and it was done quicker that takes
some of the build the hype out of all
those pieces of just watching they're
trying to figure out out on their own
they have the whole vault pieces going
on what do you do with this people in
chat watching and looking and honestly I
would rather see it that way
it's where it's harder because it kind
of takes the wind out of the sails and
when somebody beats it like three or
four hours and you're like that's like
half a shift of work and you're like hey
it's like I went to lunch and by the
time I came home and started beating
you're like well that that must not beat
that bad
I mean yeah it may have more
accessibility to it but it doesn't put
it out there on that pedestal of like
damn I really gotta grind my butt off
trying to get up there work on leveling
up and it's just one of those pieces I
think a raid should be that that is your
to epic in game I'm gonna have an armed
car which is the biggest raid busting
they've ever done and it needs that like
level of epic adventure perfect
execution mechanics damage checks all
those pieces and you know what if you go
through and you do Kali and you get to
Cyril Chi and you can't do it but you
got a piece from Kali because you're
gonna get a drop it seems anyway and you
get a small upgrading hey work on that
keep running your dailies kind of keep
your any other stuff come back next week
work on week well you know boss one and
two that's literally how it should work
that's how those love it love it
yep absolutely man absolutely and now
the people who are working on grinding
up be like hey I can't find a six-person
team yet can you find two other people
to work on the shattered throne when you
get leveled up this is another gear as
you work on leveling up and then you
might be even more overpowered when you
step in the raid before exact yo they've
got so many options for us now that I
think is a really positive turn and I
mean I can't wait for the raid I just
know I'm not ready for it yet and we do
this damn thing and I played my butt off
and so do you and I'm not ready both I'm
two characters of 550 I don't even have
my third went up there I haven't even
done the kiss story on my third one
because I'm like there's another like
six hours yeah like and it's it's a
grind it's gonna be real but it's just
gonna lose I know oh absolutely and in
the last point we'll put the yeah I
don't work but it's just a great topic I
know we've been going on it put on the
last one I put on it is actually me
doing it the first time underleveled
made me a better play because when I got
there I was realizing things I can get
away with what I couldn't get away with
what would difficult points it made me
change out my lord I made me think of
more effective things that when I came
back stronger
like it was a breeze on a certain
problem I okay I know what to do I'm
saying like it was like trial by fire so
that's the other thing like seeing what
works seeing what I was learning about
subclasses like even for the Sherrill
Chi being about speed and I'm like you
know what even though I got my well let
me go don't bleep because I need to
assist my team with ADD clearing you
know I'm saying and doing that whole
thing so again that's another thing I
took from it and like you said that
content being hard you getting grouped
together you achieving things in
progression in steps and it just it's
great I already love it and it just adds
to the law of the raid I mean let's be
honest like you know who was this good
go through a few do day one you plays
everything out then what you kind of
like done with the content no no no yeah
I'm like I agree it's like I don't mind
the grind and I'll sign people like oh
you know other games are coming out in a
few weeks I'm not gonna have as much of
a grinder and a much time to do stuff I
mean and that's the point where the fall
is the crazy fall and we understand some
people are like a Spider Man came out
and want to do that spider-man will wait
for a single-player if you if you I mean
and if this is your thing otherwise just
know it's like you know we're gonna have
some expansion come out you know the
small annual pass first piece with the
forge I don't know if they're gonna bump
light level and stuff like that if they
do they'd be kind of cool a smaller bump
but I didn't want to see some bum I
don't want to be 0 if there's any story
involved but we'll just have to see how
it goes but it's like this will still be
waiting when you want to and if you want
to jump away remember that's always fine
exactly
alright so that kind of covers the raid
topic for now so we'll kind of scroll
down and get into we got a new crucible
mode and have you had a chance to touch
this thing
I have not that's how crazy is Wednesday
or Thursday and be like hey played this
like once maybe twice that I have you
touched the finish did you even touch
when it was in crucible labs right I
don't think I did I don't remember
because I played the very first one just
like showdown or something and that was
just kind of like a tweak on clash with
just rounds like yeah first of 15 kills
or something you do it three times like
that was different this
got actual objectives to it and it's
kind of double objectives I played a few
rounds I got smoked in some we smoked
teams and others there is kind of a
weird piece right now because there are
two objectives mm-hmm slow wait game
mode works everybody fights over the
center point like King the hill but once
you have that point then you start
pushing towards your opposing teams like
base and you actually have to cap their
point and that's how you actually win
the round
but if you get the middle point and then
they defend theirs for the final amount
of time you completely lose that round
so you still got halfway but you don't
get anything for it and somehow I feel
like that doesn't quite be equivalent
points I think it should be potentially
like you know up to a certain number
points if you get the middle point maybe
one point then if you get there like
they call it a vault
if you cap their vault then that should
be too but if you go one and one it
should be a draw of some point because
you nailed the first part and I was on
one map or we were playing back and
forth for time and we literally neither
capped the first one Wow look that
middle point you can fight because it
takes a long time to capture and if you
get you know 3/4 through the capture and
they step on it they literally have to
like retract your capture time and then
go all the way through there so it's a
slow process as you go through that
middle point then once you finally have
that one you have a little closer spawn
to push but on the other side say you go
in and you've got it you you know you
have two people on a super or something
like that if you both are hammers you
kill their team you stand on the point
these respawn times are so long in this
thing you can't get back into findit
fast enough so it's literally both sides
that it definitely I feel like needs
some tweaks but personally I really wish
this was going to both quick play and
competitive because I hate that it's
just gonna dive in competitive and the
hardly everyone yeah that's a good point
I didn't think about that forget that
it's it's a competitive technically
exclusive mode once it breaks out of
this little spotlight so yeah that's a
good point I mean I'm definitely going
to try it after I get all my powers
differently but I would be able to try I
think what they need to do if I they
were smart they really want people to
get in that mode it's kind of tie it to
a quest that you could get powerful gear
by attempting it because - to me that's
a brain like it's so intelligent that
they
did that was far as gambit that forces
me to play gambit exactly every week
people in a powerful gear check I mean
that's the new wave now with this type
of grin soon as you see on your screen
that gold star and powerful gear I'm
going working on now I would did heroic
or it's I don't know the buddy of mine
he's like what is this is this some like
I don't remember this mission I was like
Finn Adventure and I was like after
doing all the I'm trying to figure out
what they're called V Soulstice gear
because we did still like 30 different
adventures I've done most of them now he
was like what is this I was like it's an
adventure he's like oh I didn't make
these before I'm giving you a reason to
see him out because those have
interesting change every day don't do it
on the first day we if the reset clicks
over but it's not like the heroic tick
like every morning still change the
adventure same thing when it was on
tangled shore last week it was a
different barren like everyday basically
I saw the writer I saw the rifleman
couple different ones in there that it
would cycle through and you're like hey
just depending on the day you jump in I
need something different so that was
cool yeah it'd be kind of nice for them
to have that Weekly featured playlists
get a little more hype to it yes those
like you got supremacy you'll have a
couple things rotate through there and
get make people go play that little mode
for just a little bit or just give them
incentive to try something a little
different than just your basic quick
play if you like just yet hate two
matches in this you know a piece of
powerful gear it's all in that one light
level bump anyway some of those aren't
even doing that much for me at some
point but it's still away just that
incentive to get people in have to but
it be an option to get more in there
yeah I'm with you you know so I do
actually like that for given incentive
for that Weekly featured I just wish
this thing wasn't gonna go hide in
competitive because we could use another
I mean quickly I'm in control and clash
are cool and quit play I'm in there easy
matches stuff like that but we still
need some more variety in there I hope
these maps or more in quick play I feel
like I don't know if I've seen them yet
I don't even know if they're going to
because they're built for breakthrough
yeah and I'd hate to see four I played
breakthrough on banner fall which was
weird by the way really yes
so I mean be point was the middle vault
and then the other two sides were
exactly you picture them to be so you
had the two rooms but I mean picture the
spawn locations if they're standing
there and you spawn in your back corner
of your base you still have to jump up
on the ledge run in there and by the
time two or three you're sitting on the
base if a one or two sitting on the
walls and one standing on the vault you
cannot hardly get in there and kick them
off of it in time so that's the spawn
points like if you're on defense making
that harder cuz it's like two two and a
half minutes that you have to defend it
make it worthwhile fight yeah no I agree
I completely agree I mean I gotta try
this I know once you play it cuz I'll
kind of be curious your thoughts pon
times in the middle and then the far one
things like that but I just do hope we
get to see more of these vaults because
some of them look really cool ones from
like the kind of trials of the nine
world stuff that we had one map from
before I only played a couple to a
couple different maps I've keep seeing
the same two there's like two I haven't
even touched yet for breakthrough so but
they look cool I just hope we get to see
those but all in all breakthrough is
kind of an interesting concept it's an
objective mode and I just feel we need
more of those and it's kind of an
interesting like double objective kind
of like I'm trying to think of a
battlefield mode where it's like you get
one part and then you kind of push back
to like the next phase of like almost
like that so you like you do the middle
and then you do like the defense if you
get pushed back but it's like instead of
conquest where you're always on defense
right you start with the king of the
hill and then it's defense or offense so
interesting what if you guys haven't
checked it out play a couple matches let
us know you know comment stuff later on
and see what you guys think about the
mode and just leave some feedback to
Bungie just make it constructive don't
be a Cosmo and Dylan those guys actually
that's their whole purpose so be like
hey this is their thoughts they're even
out there asking Kosmos like what are
your thoughts on breakthrough so far
they asked go find that tweet and reply
they read that stuff their whole job so
yeah just decent thoughts on it whether
it's good bad or otherwise mm-hmm agreed
all right we got a big topic this is one
week last week because we ran out of
time so it's probably the most high def
image we're ever gonna get on that
scoreboard which I guess will now be
course I don't even know so first before
we actually dive into this what are your
thoughts on master what courses they
currently stand um
there needs to be some adjustment
because here's the thing as a hardcore
Destin player as a person who prepared
for forsaken you know during you know
the war mine prep phase you know
basically I kept a lot of stuff in my
fault all right I kept masterworks in my
vault
I was completely unsure how the meta was
gonna swing either way I was come save
tokens with shacks I mean I went through
a systematic process of holding on to
things because didn't know how to meta
was gonna change didn't know what
weapons would be effective I knew random
rows and all that stuff was coming but I
always figured that hey some of these
God roll you know d2 weapons you know
aka the nameless midnight I had master
work better Devils I had mass work some
iron being kind banner gear sets you
name it I kept it right so Wow forsaking
launches we start I start playing I'm
like okay cool and then I'm like you
know got my first you know highlight
drop I'm like all right let's get the
infusing so I'm like okay cool and then
I'm like whoa what's this requiring two
core thing and besides the requiring the
core I was like asking for a good amount
of legendary shards and I'm like okay
they weren't infusing a half wait I have
a problem with that honestly initially
but as it went on it got to the point
because again to be speaking to my
situation right I'm a type of person
that when it comes to hard content and
I'm trying to do stuff that's under
level because the grinding forsaken is
hard so I was very on the level and I'm
like you know what I can't be going
through the game without my sleeper
simulant and my escalation shotgun those
two weapons did not leave my energy did
not leave my power
whenever anything of significance came
that way whether it be at least from a
three to five point light jump those bad
boys are getting infused after about
getting to about 500 light my materials
getting low
I'm like uh he got to the beautifully
during the story and like up to 500 bro
I was almost drew it was it was good it
was I was going through a man in an
alarm and great and I wasn't doing it
for just like one light level bomb I was
like you know the story is not gonna be
already need to start doing that I know
but the problem was we was still
undelivered I was getting unlucky
nowadays when you get unlucky ya
campaign I did it solo and I thought
that for 60 final fight of like 443 I
had no business in there fighting
whoever I was fighting oh good don't
save me is I'm gonna running well of
Radiance
you know I got some competent teammates
but for the most part I was severely
under level I wasn't getting lucky with
the drops for infusion so you know it
was becoming a problem and then like I
said as you go dude out of five 30s and
and you're growing and growing on cause
because I'm going to Sparta and then we
find out the hustle of the spider
alright and you know with extensive play
time I've realized you know masterwork
core drops are not really happening like
rarely you'll break down laser you get
one rarely you'll get that what does it
call mast or something we've where yeah
really I got that and they start let me
try bad II got two of those I haven't
even clicked them yet exactly no I have
three finest matter wave and I'm like
yep that's them but it literally is
worth what 3-course afraid of those in I
don't even know how many hours in
playing got to be a hundred I had three
mad I was a plan and I'm like okay so
you know what let me tell how bad it got
your boy had to stop making trips to the
ATM that's how bad it is I started going
to my fault say hmm you break down
better Devils uh looks like there's
random roles and that there's a
collection system I can always get you
back later
breakdown for car breakdown because I
literally went through everything in
Italy nothing was sacred raid weapons I
was like look man I could get you back
seeing it zenith of your kind I can get
you back and all girly dress it's the
core grind like I feel bad for a person
who infused like me who didn't have any
of this backlog of you know immense
legendary weapons and stuff that's in
their vault children if you have to play
let's just say put it this way put
yourself in a player who Jess picked up
forsaken gonna say yeah the forsaken
collection went through all three
stories and they gentleman a forsaken
they have no backups and they have no
materials anyway they have like zero
well yeah I literally have not like
acquired outside of as you said random
drops but I mean unless you broke down a
masterwork that you had you're not gonna
get that you'll have like a couple not
have enough yeah man
listen I'm with you and I feel bad cuz
I'm like if I'm struggling what is a guy
who did like you said it was in that
situation doing how is he able to level
up and that's when I realized yeah as
much as I like that infusion is a choice
and you have to make it tough in scale
they I think they make the mistake of
assuming most of the base is the hard
core base that come along with them you
know I'm saying and that may have this
vault that can do some things to kind of
offset but yeah it has to get tweaked so
seeing these updates that we're about to
get into really I'm impressed will get
first you get into it and then will far
as your experience with it cuz you asked
me the question I asked you the question
how do you feel about it and then we'll
get into what they are now about to do
oh I'm the same way but I've been very
stingy I haven't leveled anything I've
literally just been playing as somebody
would with the drops I've got guys might
be here well there's 40,000 edged
transits whatever grenade-launcher
because good things are good pretty good
spot so it's like it's okay that I've
got 50 of them but yeah I mean you
picture yourself because me right now as
I've been stingy as hell I've leveled a
couple things up here and there
I'll occasionally go like okay I see
something has a pretty good roll in
range and I have some cores I may dump
one into it I have a hundred
ninety-seven course I'm saving because
I'm saving I've been hoarding that's
kind of those things like picture myself
not walking in with about a hundred and
eighty I've thrown a few here I've got a
few back I've gone through him broken
down most I've got another couple other
master works I might break down but it
was like if I didn't have all that crap
I broke down in the first place I would
have squat and that's that is a problem
to me because there has been no obvious
way to burns it they're ugly tokens out
of my butt there's world materials
spider does these things there's a
useless cloak guy up in a tree that you
caught him up because that's what broke
my heart when last week's sir and I'm
like okay I figured for sure I was like
bungees not stupid they're probably
gonna treat him like the strange coins
things that God made me give him
bounties everything he gave me bounties
to that point so much and when I see
inertia with all these exotics and no
nothing special just that not even the
faded Engram not that I cared about that
not even the tree of coins
not that I care about that but just to
see him so barren he's just like you
didn't come out here wouldn't so yeah
back to your point sir I was very
surprised at that soul you know it's one
of those things that like you said not
having a definitive way resource to get
them really puts a damper on in future
yeah well here's the other piece do you
even think they should be part of
infusion
not like at all yeah probably not
probably not um I do like the thought
process - I'm gonna be honest I do like
what they like theory right but I don't
think what there's already so much crap
we have to manage and bounties and other
things and now we might get a couple
couple more bounties there's a point
where my bounties are full my persons
can give ya either give me another page
give me a place to work on the stuff
because if I'm holding on to some saved
a couple from a previous day finished a
couple Klan bounties that I'm not gonna
turn in because I'm already done with
those for the week and I'll just save it
for next week right all those it's like
one like I might be able to fit one in
here there but an infusion is meant to
be like master working should be that
and that's where we look given the whole
name thought about it yeah and I know
that wanted people like as you go
through to like be a little more what I
mean yeah shout out to politest he he
said it pretty well I was like I was
reading his article recently and it was
basically saying it's like so you have
the hard core people that had enough
materials that it really didn't matter
that much anyway they did the raid that
master worked what they needed to and
they were as high as they could be then
you have the middle person like you and
me whether I hoarded them or whether you
didn't we had something with but we're
getting to the point where it's like
crap I'm basically to the point of
they're too hard to come by some afraid
to use them or if I use them all I have
no way to get any back exactly and then
you have your fresh to the game on
PlayStation they may but more say come
for 40 bucks and now they're just like
what the hell do I do now like I can't
get these things but it's this and it's
that piece of frustration just to even
level up your gear be like hey I got a
thousand different roles oh ok if I'm
gonna go run in iron banner where power
matters but I don't want to spend it
just for a week of something when I'm
gonna get another role later on like you
take the incentive out of leveling
yourself up so you're like well I guess
I'm just running at a disadvantage and
that shouldn't be
I can go grind help you know world
materials legendary shards if you're
playing and prices doing your bounties
and doing your chest and doing public
you're gonna get an acquisition of those
right the core is out of that it's not
it's one more thing we don't need and
unless they just start throwing a lot of
them at us just so we can have the
chance for infusion and master working
which is right but yet it's just too
much which is what I agree which is said
I'm not
no really I'm not on this side where you
are where I'm upset that they exist my
whole thing is what you the second part
of what you said which is it should just
be from master working well if that's
the case yes because of the terminology
I agree with that but I'm talking about
being that we gonna get into it they're
gonna change the name but yeah what I'm
saying is this where the unbalanced lies
is the fact that like you said when you
need planetary materials right for your
gun you go to devaron kay you get your
bounties for dust like shards there is
no equivalent for masterwork cards of
course currently that is the problem
yeah it's a discrepancy it's a disparity
every other place if I need all these
other planetary materials there's a
there's a place there's a vendor and he
even has bounties that gives me bushels
of 10 right where's my bushels of 10
masterwork horse right now you know what
I learned with the bushel of 10 actually
allows it it's not even something that
is consistent it's actually grunt I
grinded crucible when it was what xxx be
recently yeah did all that because you
know I'm still I'm on my wretched crappy
oh I'm doing so well I'm I'm up to
double kills part I'm almost finished
with that I'm grinding I got 2050 poles
for oh I'm pulling I'm a piece did you
see my arm clip on Twitter by the way 17
challenger 1770 no efficiency 7 kills in
a row
oh man I'm doing through some things I
just like pull my chest voice lock
forever but anyway right now they're
gonna they gonna bang tangent they're
gonna ban that void lock in a minute I'm
just I'm putting it out there that void
like once you master it you unlock that
full tree when you get that poof and you
get your health back then you hold down
and you kill multiple people with the
supernova that's gonna get in there I
know buddy people gonna start
complaining because the things that I'm
doing it's criminal it's criminal to
peace I've never been this good I mean
I'm good I'm above average and sixes I'm
saying I'm I'm a bum average and
competitive in fours and sixes I've
always been strong but what I doing now
is like put me in the room with the top
do I'm cashing them
that's what I'm doing right now the
efficiency so back to my point the whole
thing is when I'm being I'm doing so
good and I'm leveling up when I got to
mythic they you know congratulations
mythic and it was like Bowl like seven
cores ten I'm like whoa that's what I'm
talking about now they need now people
shouldn't have to do all that you know
I'm saying to get it but they need that
equivalent is basically what they want
the whole point of this is they just
know a specific activity specific vendor
you know bounties all these combinations
of things to get this thing going
because it is way too rare and
unnecessary to put in his infusion if
you don't got the source to get them
yeah so well yeah as you guys can see we
have our opinions about this for sure
and many many other people have
mentioned this as well so they said they
asked the investment team to talk about
some of the goals with mr. workhorse
exotic drop rates we'll get to in a
little bit right I said they've been
monitoring to communities feedback
concerning master workers quick
breakdown on their design of course so
both for attic master work course two
infusion costs make infusion and master
working a meaningful choice I don't mind
that at least in theory unfortunately
just the balance of it is broken
infusion master work should not be
mutually exclusive
hmm now that to me is weird yeah because
they're also saying they it's I would
say it's a contradiction but it does
seem weird that the first sentence would
say beautiful choice between both and
then the second to say should have
mutually exclusive so you're gonna make
me spend course you're gonna make me
spend this currency just a level the gun
up to a certain light level then you're
gonna make me spin cores to make me you
know or con say this role has like hey
this I've got it better Devils with
explosive rounds and outlaw and
stability cool okay I'm gonna master
work it spend it for this now I don't
know if you break it down if you get
every single piece back I'm not sure but
if you do level up and then what if I
get one with range with those exact same
person like well crap I want the range
and where do you turn around it's like
then do I have to infuse that one up
spin course that's some I'm already down
and then depending on the efficiency of
breaking the one
you mast work down to get some back
you're always like the infusion piece
shouldn't be there like if you're gonna
spend your money on master working you
better love that gun that I totally
understand
yes master working should be a
meaningful choice don't master work like
you know you spend one get that thing up
to light rank for it's only one have a
toy with it before you spend all your
course right but in giving something up
to your level when you're already up
there and if it's a drop you got a while
ago whether you bump it a lot of you
bump it a little I know they're wanting
you to play with some of the guns you've
got but take the damn cores out of the
infusion to me right I think what
they're saying is that I think I
understand a sentence now when you leave
the next sentence you can read the next
it cuz basically what the next sentence
says I think is why they they said what
they said you know let's get into Kermit
ya problems with the current must work
or economy that's what courts have a
misleading name which is the main thing
we kept talking about basically touching
on apparently they're thinking of these
things just as like course like maybe it
could just be gear cores if you wanted
to call that armor weapons whatever when
they were created the definition of the
pinnacle I hadn't put the emphasis on
entirely mess word that is literally all
they ever did before right now as this
has come into infusion they said they
expanded that definition forsaken but
didn't update the currency they're not
enough reliable sources to earn master
of course uh-huh
we can make deciding to spend on what to
spend them on too difficult somebody
like me I spend none I don't have a tier
10 unless it was a drop you get lens for
addressing these problems we have been
warped monitoring course applies the
numbers aren't as high as we'd like
we're planning to create more reliable
and plentiful core sources we're going
to rename s where cores so their purpose
is more obvious yeah I think listen I
think this is a great update I mean
listen we will all bitchin right now and
I get it and then rightfully so but um I
think this is cool I think to me when I
read this they're jumping ahead of it
they're letting me know letting us know
what the their intention with what I
like what they're doing this day letting
us know their thought process why they
did what they did then they're saying
okay this is the feedback we got from
you guys and now based on this we're
doing I think this is aka new Bungie Co
Bungie doesn't do these paragraphs
right new Bungie says this what we did
is why we did it
this is why we think it was wrong this
is what you said this is now what we're
gonna do love it love it because this is
quick concise get to the point and that
the addressing the problem is yeah they
weren't named incorrectly they shouldn't
be mutually exclusive and if you're
gonna make this thing a requirement give
us more sub sources give us more numbers
they seen the numbers I like that so I'm
cool I'm loving that this just me
personally how are you like are you like
yeah a little too little too late they
waiting too long it's too stupid it was
stupid to begin with where are you which
is holding a little of all I mean a
little of both a little of a couple of
phrases at at the end where I'm like so
just like some other times I feel like
they've done in expansions we're like
hey we're gonna set this up so you have
to blow through whatever currency you
currently have so then it's gonna kind
of be an equalizer for people like that
coming in or not well you have the
people who probably have like 500 master
workers they do the raid they have
plenty of stuff there are still okay the
people with the middle ground who may
have had like 50 they infused a couple
things crap I'm out I can't get any more
and now they're coming to this thing
later on some people may have been a
little frustrated there's been enough
good things that I don't think people
have bailed on account of just this
alone but this has been one of the
biggest points of contention right
though it was probably pretty obvious
from the beginning and I don't think was
ever required and I don't think they
ever should have done in the first place
I don't think okay but like to me I
don't think the cores ever needed to be
an infusion making master works more
difficult and like the currency not
being high they can see that later and
maybe you don't have like you know a
level 10 master work on you know all
your guns immediately and that's gonna
be something they fix later but just
bringing stuff up in light level just to
be able to play with all the 14,000
roles that we have is one of those
things I don't think they should have
done in the first place so to me that's
just my opinion of kind of an oversight
and playing more towards hold on Billy
the Kid when you guys on the pumpkin
[Music]
literally broke me mid-sentence
I'm gonna have to read this out loud
because I'm not even sure I get it when
you guys on the podcast poop where
that's going
: think about how awesome podcasters and
makes you feel that good well I don't
listen to this podcast over no like you
know stroke my own ego yeah well I
listen to the podcast is like who knows
this you guys enjoy the podcast so how's
your time great Liz the Bears enjoy a
salute ability care at the end of the
day listen as long as you appreciate the
content and give us that compliment in
whatever form that makes you know
walking your dogs or taking a dump up to
you
but uh the back of a check yeah I'm glad
they're making the changes I'm glad they
have acknowledged it as you said this is
new Bungie this is something we may not
have seen for a while this is something
they may have like waited longer on the
data made the point zero one percent
damage changes like that type of stuff
was the work and I do like that they are
trying I know we're like three weeks in
so I mean it does take some time to get
to some fixes and check data and see
where things settle and sometimes people
could jump the gun and it could be
something too quick but in turn I could
probably have told you this from pretty
early on when looking at those costs of
both infusion and how much for master
works and me sucking I was even sitting
at 180 basically going in and I was like
I'm not gonna touch these things because
I don't know where I'm gonna get them
and as much as they were gonna cost I
was like hey let's see what rolls I get
running as I kept playing through just
even go through the story I was like I
got zero through the entire story got to
the dreaming city like technically
there's I could have gone through like
20 hours of playing scene zero master or
course and some new person could be like
how the hell do I do this I've got none
yet
yeah zero like so there's a point where
if you just play through and there was
some testing involved to be like hey I'm
played 20 hours to have any master what
course is a fresh new character no okay
that I mean that should have been one of
those pieces where they saw it as a
problem so I think earlier reaction or
just better testing to say hey this is
one of those pieces somewhere there
needs to be half one you know six level
one half dozen another a way to it
whatever something need to probably have
probably beaten scene sooner but that's
my opinion but I am glad they
are addressing and giving us some
options what would you like to see is
giving us options I know you mentioned
like serve bounties I think would be
cool give him something to do over the
weekend um what else I mean where would
you where do you think this fits what do
you think massive outside of spider work
in the casino gambling oh yeah like I
said you know our Caesars two reasons
number one if they want to keep rarity
but the vibe I'm getting is now you know
they may go multiple sources so it can't
be just him I'm thinking in the gunsmith
right now he doesn't have a lot going on
you know um it's about leveling your gun
you know I'm saying so armor so let's
make him more viable or we can do
something with him he doesn't have bound
he's currently the only thing he's doing
right now is offering just the the mods
that change up you know so that to me
he's the viable pick I see you know for
doing stuff and yeah just back to my
point you know I know you I know we're
on a different side of the fence with
this and everything is saying you're not
incorrect yeah I get what you're coming
from I guess for me I just liked it
because you know it did make a choice it
did make me say okay which out of these
weapons that I've been using then I'm
just quiet do I like and I had to make a
commitment I did get a relationship I'm
saying okay come on go figure this is
gonna be me and you yeah you know come
on such a such gun I like this it's a
nice role you know whatever whatever now
I agree with the part that you say where
if you get multiple roles of really good
things it sucks you know because you
don't have the cores and then you know
you're kind of just taking whatever the
highest light you you know you don't get
a chance to experience these things
because things are at lower light
sometimes when you get them or you know
whatever so I get that but I do like the
the aspect because here's the big
picture reason why I like it is less be
really if that didn't exist in all US
hardcore players we're gonna do every
powerful gear on that map we are going
to level up and blaze through the
content I think this is their way of
kind of cooling the hardcore a little
bit because we're out of control
we're gonna do every single drop on that
map in like three days after we set
have every we're gonna be 600 in no time
see that's my thing my thing is levels
you up though so that's not the point it
doesn't give you a higher level it lets
you experience your guns as you level up
that's my difference wait you're talking
about when I'm talking to you
yep okay yeah so if I get it say I get
my I got my Zen moment full I'll go
figure at 500 mm-hmm okay so I level up
keep going through it starts to fall
back mm-hmm do I keep infusing it same
up okay okay I want this is like the
average player go for it somebody has
maybe three cores cuz they got lucky
right are they gonna spin those three
cores that they have a limited resource
on when they're like hey I'm up to 520
well I'm just gonna keep using this 500
piece of gear and I'm starting to fight
stuff that's like five 40 by 50 I'm
walking are in the Dreaming City no I'm
gonna use what's there then they can't
actually use that gun it does make them
do other things but it's like why if you
want to Matt if you want to make
something an epic version of what you've
got where that's where I think that
limited resource makes sense and that I
have no problem with and you know
getting some bounties in there for you
know limited options but if I have
something that's 500 but it's a good
role and I get so that go figures that
okay so I got one that drops at 5:30 now
but this one sucks in comparison right I
want to go use the other one right so
it's just those pieces I don't think see
that's where we differ I think you think
you're a hardcore you're not 600 and
people are 600 those are the hardcore
people we are far from casual is what I
would call it we play a load but we are
not like the people who beat the raid on
the first weekend or even this week at
all absolutely the point of those are
the people where the currency has never
been an issue for them because they
already streamed for 6000 hours last
year and they have a boatload of hours
absolutely.we and when you go from us
and then you go anywhere below like the
best reasonable a huge problem a problem
in that little problem you have to take
the full aspect of players the majority
of them are below us right and I'm with
you on that
all I'm saying and we both agree that
there should be more sources for course
all I'm saying is I don't want to get
rid of course
because I still like the idea of a
choice being made between what you have
to select because if there's no course
then infuse all the way up as you level
you're gonna get to max level much
faster I like the idea of having
ownership of something that I feel is a
great role or if there's something new
that comes along then I make that choice
per gun per armor or what have you it
just is just a philosophy difference I
mean no but I'm saying what I'm saying
is it doesn't level you up any faster it
doesn't make your light grow any quicker
if there's no course there are if
there's no course anything is getting
infused into anything and you're gonna
get to max light that's just the fact no
but as long as you have that gun
somewhere in your vault basically it's
still gonna account for your light level
it doesn't matter if you're using it or
infusing it or not it's just the fact
that your lower level gun that you want
to use you're not writing to use right
you just have an empty gun sitting there
just for a light level it's not gonna
make you infusion is not gonna make you
level up any faster that's what I'm
trying to get at to me how it will
because seriously like if I'm gonna go
through and say like okay let me tell
you we not go agree on this little bit
let me just explain myself remember what
I said my favorite loadout escalation
protocol shotgun which in my opinion is
best at that class in that energy smart
and sleeper in my plane which is if I
focus on the two best weapons I'm going
to if I have the best quality rolls in
the best weapons and I just load those
up I can go through content severely on
the level that's what I'm trying to say
like there's still guns that even though
they're not the higher light they're
still gonna be effective because of the
roll rolls dominate you said I'm saying
that's what I'm saying so I see the
thought process of what they're trying
to do is all I'm saying it's trying to
from us a little bit because it will get
out of control and we might get doing
content that's what I'm saying but I
hear what you're saying in theory yeah
like the other higher light gun you just
throw that journal on and you're good to
go so I get it I just understand waiting
what trying what they were trying to do
is what I'm saying fair enough well
enough perspective your drops are not
change infusion can you do some content
a little bit easier with sleeper coming
up the whole time yes yes you can but
also on the other side it's like you're
not gonna change the number that's gonna
work for some things but you're still
your weeklies your dailies things like
that you can do it with any gun I've
done it all so the only thing that
that's gonna help you with is like what
you get through one rate boss I don't
know everything else you don't accept
that rate boss
dude I've done it I can do a lot with
that loadout it's it's criminal but I
don't know but like it oh we both agree
something has to be changed yes our guys
from a long tangent we both agree that
it's still flawed right and it's dude
yes so this is cool I like the address
in it you like today addressing it you
met them gone I want them to stay but at
the end of the day something at least in
the short term is gonna get done smiled
or without yep so so this is one of the
big ones obviously master of cours
infusion master working all that stuff
like I don't even master or karma right
now and that's one thing tessie did
actually say to shout out to him i've
not master worked one piece of armor yet
and that's a piece where the core is an
infusion is one piece because then
you're gonna try and master work hey I
get a good of role on this piece of
armor it's linear fusion scavenger
linear fusion reserves that's something
you would probably look for since that's
all you had speaking well anyways but
for what if for you oh yeah so simple
gaming that's just literally on Monday
net that's all I'm looking at is their
weekly update um is the point where
armor I haven't touched because I know
I'm oh I'm already going to get
something else I'm gonna get another
roll over and over and over and it's
like so then the point of just trying to
bring armor along with you then you're
not even talking about weapons you're
trying to bring the arm rolls that you
know all of those pieces it's just like
an exacerbation of the same thing but
arm world you're gonna get thousand more
rolls of and it's just kind of tough to
kind of keep up yeah we know more gonna
come but it's like if you get a roll
with like linear fusion reserves
you're like well crap I have to hold on
to this thing forever infused and views
and views and views and views and
pictures almost nobody who's brand new
be like hey I've won in fusion rifle I
did them our story here sleeper simulant
I have no course just picture yourself
in the shoes of course yes yes oh that's
the problem where I don't think in you
could enjoy that roll up through but you
couldn't masterwork that armor without
the cores and Max would be a piece but
you could use the so it's like it's yeah
underneath underneath what you said you
said the perfect statement the the raid
guys the first day ray guys and then
it's us right anyone under us and that
this system screws them screws them like
they're not gonna have the cause they're
not gonna have anything so that in that
case week like I do agree with you you
got to think of the whole they have to
address it because those guys are
screwed they're not they don't have
anything to put into anything they have
to take whatever is coming their way
you said I'm saying so I get it I
completely get that yeah absolutely
so random question chat since before I
get to another topic and roll a little
farther oMG it's cool what do you guys
think about the wish and or exotic quest
now it's behind every three weeks cycle
on being able to access the mission
allowed is you to get it kind of touched
on it earlier but like just generally
like an exotic meantime tied behind a
three week time gated thing and just
also that dungeon basically coming up
only every three weeks for you to get
the wish endure for to get the high
level gear stuff like that what do you
think yeah I think did we think we
touched on it um listen I don't I don't
have a problem with it you know I'm
saying I sound like I'm that I don't
have a problem with it guy lately you're
the you're the Bungie gobbly apologist
I'm the bungee apologist today oh yeah
just you know I guess you know for for
me it doesn't bother me if I can't get
something on day one I'm gonna get it
like that's just how my mentality is and
it just you know unless it's something
you know I don't know they would have to
I don't really think there's any
particular thing you know I'm saying
that if it comes out and it's great and
it's awesome even like there's a lot of
things I didn't have day one a lot of
things I wanted a what I didn't get it
you know what I want right now and
you're way too long
exactly you know what I want right now
worse than anything forgettable again
guess it it's even laughs the sea
persimmon a catalyst
I love no we got a raid team together
and we do inspire we got up to on the
final part work a lower yet I'm saying
it was a new raid team we're just trying
to teach everybody because at least we
were over level trying to do it you know
say now just a matter of doing mechanics
so that's something I've wanted I want
bad right but I'm like okay I looked at
the quest steps I'm like I don't have
all three escalation weapons I got the
sniper and I got the shotty don't have
the SMG right then the whisper you got
is still max all your stuff I'll I still
have to finish the other parts of the
whisper crust by you and I'm saying as
far as max yeah I can tell a little
thing I'll show you how plug my man
exactly boxes video I'm gonna watch that
so again I'm sitting like in my mind I'm
gonna get it you know it's just it's
gonna happen when it happens and then
these things that come across my way
like right now I got on the raid this
raid Auto ten level ten tier master work
did you get like the god roll from
Bungie
that's how destiny is to me so I get it
people like hey I'm not around that week
I get that that sucks
no doubt you gotta wait three weeks okay
cool you know a person with a busy
schedule or they're traveling I I get it
I do have some sympathy for I don't
think I'm just being ridiculous but you
know I really can't sit there and say yo
ya gotta change this I'm just not there
yet I'm not at that point with you you
guys have to you know because this is
unfair because this week to chart doing
it and i'ma have to wait till next month
or what I'll wait two three weeks or
whatever I mean that's just me
ya know I mean I
yeah I was like shadow to the dude in
the iron Lords podcast YouTube chat by
the way so if you guys weren't which by
the way we're doing this on two
different places so thank you guys um
but I think he said it like well just a
carrot on the end of its tear down the
end his dick mm-hmm we were missing for
a very long time yes and in fact that we
have those out there and if I miss it
for the week or I'm out be like hey
three weeks I'm gonna make sure you know
try and plan for it make sure I got a
little extra time and work on this thing
and while I'm doing that there's still a
crapload of other stuff to do I say
you're up to like 570 and you're like
okay let's see about working on the raid
or I can work on grinding gammet until I
see the tentacle monster in there so I
can get my malfeasance there's you know
other quests that you can do if you
haven't done a sub spades if you have an
unchaperoned if you haven't done render
exclaim or some of you guys hate PvP
skips render Claymore but you'll get
your few matches in and your work on
your powerful gear and there may be a
point where as you go through you'll
kind of get tore this see this would be
the question go win the grind slows as
you get towards the top end when you're
working on the final stuff when you get
close to 600 and you feel like you've
kind of done a lot of stuff then will
there be still continued things is the
timing right to where Forge comes out
right um and this is where I think this
cycle helps some of that yes and I don't
think it's them
like forcefully time gating things I
think it's more they're giving you
options of things to work on the rate is
out there the dungeon is out there the
ascendant challenges are out there
there's a lot of different things for
you to do you can still work on those
ascendant challenges you can still work
on your blind well your Oracle it's your
transcendent blessings you can work on
your every dawn armor i'ma get a little
really keep talking right now
so the carats there's a boatload of them
out there right now and I'm just like a
room full of carrots so Ridge yeah I
mean I think that you nailed it I think
the issue I think what's happened now
are there are so many carrots right
there's a tourniquet so I'm like okay I
don't have that one but guess what you
may be ahead of me here by having wish
ender
but guess what I may be one step away
from rhetorics you should I'm saying so
you got a pic what in my opinion what
you value the most
the only defense I see for this case
with which ender is yes that it's on a
specific cycle so it's not like
registrar can just do it every day right
I was just crying grind grind grind
where's this it's like okay only on this
weekend or whatever it is or this week
this reset you know I'm saying it's
gonna be around the only argument I
would have to say that is that I mean it
is a whole week reset it's not like
whisper in the sense remember whisper
when it came around for the weekends
just that short period of the three days
you have a weak psyche with every three
weeks yeah that sucks but it's a least a
week so when that week comes just not
gonna like you dock on those weeks to
like I don't know you don't say I don't
want to disrespect anybody schedule but
it's like you really not gonna be around
you know saying yeah I mean it's not
there's some things that are tougher
like you've got whisper on the weekends
alone if somebody works the weekends
that's gonna be a little harder so I
mean that one right hopefully you get
some time on a Sunday or whatever find
some day in there but as it is for the
full weekly or reset you get an option
to do this somewhere in there you could
travel during the week maybe spend some
time on the weekend if you got family
that's part of being an adult but all of
those pieces yeah I mean to me I don't
mind a cycle because as I was saying
before if you guys haven't checked by
video actually explains a reason for
there being a cycle and just the fact
that there's lore attached so the reason
it's not just an arbitrary BS thing I
mean you could say it kind of is but the
fact that they actually made law regs
make it make sense it was just like cool
crap I'm not gonna argue it's hard to
argue with it when the actual story
behind this whole thing actually has a
purpose so I think that for me on top of
everything else of me not being too
worried about the time gated stuff I
think just kind of makes it cool on top
of it yeah absolutely
I just want to answerability kids quick
cuz I didn't miss it I swear you
answered in my chat um he says yeah do
you think the playa base will drop a lot
by the time trials come back to where it
was when trials was dead in year one
it's a good question and like Yvonne
said like trials is fundamentally broken
I do really and I think they completely
needed a rework right so it'll be
interesting when it comes back I'm gonna
tell you what can guarantee the base to
come back literally mimic trials of
Osiris the way it was that's just me my
if it wouldn't it when they were at
their highest
when it was I mean if you're gonna go
back to the dream and elimination go
back to the reza's being a little faster
you know I'm saying trial specific maps
that kind of thing you know they've got
the formula of what was successful right
they can easy to and to me what they did
what I am bana proves to me like I am
bran when it's back to its form of no
more four six power level map it's it's
a difference you know say so just you've
got the formal of what major mode the
most successful mode and me personally
let's get Osiris back that's me
let's really put it back to what it was
because no one cares about this one
crazy chick with the one side that's
just me personally I don't care for that
law I don't it just doesn't seem cool
Osiris needs to read you know a redo
that's my thing
make him usually ain't doing nothing
anyway brother Vance ain't doing nothing
anyway so like come on it'd be perfect
to put it back to where it was you know
it was a cool little experiment with but
we didn't really get any more closure
but what the hell we were doing with
trials of the nine so that's just me
you've got the formula what I abandon
you put it back to what it was lore wise
and um gameplay wise let's do the same
for trials let's get our Egyptian gear
back let's go to mercury let's make it
read man eliminated let's put the Reza's
up a little bit
I'm good money at that point man see I
think one way they can actually build
hype for it but elimination in crucible
labs and make people freaked out yeah
like they're like I'm actually trying
this is this gonna be trials what Lee
when they get a feel for what that modes
gonna be put that crap in crucible labs
and make that hype train build up again
that's you're gonna get people talking
people thinking about people come back
to try it yeah I was like me I was never
great at trials in the first place but
the concept behind it the card all those
things I mean it was it was definitely a
hell of a challenge like there was one
of those that me the only time I got
there I straight-up got backpack carried
one hundred percent saying good day yeah
so I mean the only time I made it was
with massive help because I am NOT a new
elite crucible level
but people want that back and crucible
right now still doesn't feel like you
can make those moments those team shots
Snipes like now the roles are back which
will help but I still right now
I hear competitive is just Telesto right
oh no I mean listen I can talk about
competitive all day one thing that you
just made me remember is on the the
booms the bounties that they had stuff
in place that even if you weren't the
hardcore guy if you just played a couple
of matches if you did remember the
mother veins ponies Knowles was so key
for the middle to lower level guy who's
not gonna go to the lighthouse so they
they had then okay bull if you got the
five wins you're gonna get this you can
get something if you get SEP like they
had things to still incentivize people
going into the mode where it wasn't just
the elite of the elite and then also the
problem back then was the meta sucked
when trials with a nine but it was not
good
so now you have a better better and I'm
saying you put everything back in place
make it Egyptian the I'm gonna put up
man I'm gonna hit up on damage man
I'm gonna had a baron I've hit the
bumper get bad that's what we need we
need the trials that we all love all the
way back every aspect of it back in that
form you do that it can do it man I
really could that mode during House of
wolves when it was very it was a very
bad time for destiny before taking King
and trials kept Destiny alive I don't
care what nobody says those yeah man
thought that thing man it was people
were every weekend and the superhero
plays the clutch reza's I mean that was
a thing let's just do it I know the
fourth person sounds nice but maybe
cohesively it just doesn't work you know
I mean I don't know you know like the
good people can take two on one
especially ready options they've got now
if you have four sitting in a group that
team shooting is still just too fast
yeah anyway thanks both questions keep
them coming that's kind of why we're
doing this line so you guys can be part
of this
the next piece exotic drop rates hashtag
Longpoint by the way guys it's gonna be
a lengthy one so sorry kognito in
advance for your sleep
exotic drop rates Before we jump into
just their quick thoughts on these what
are your thoughts on these so far I have
to bend
I started off very strong
I started off strong
and part of me still does but I am
bending in the sense that bro
played so much hours of God dude I still
don't have a forsaken exotic now one and
I think the issue literally which we'll
get into what their solution will be is
um I think what I thought was gonna
happen was the hard level content would
be the sources right yeah I'm not even
though looks like the nice fall is not
giving it you know the it's so literally
random you know so orangey with the you
know the lowest of orangey that it's
still not happening and then when it
does happen I'm like bro yeah I can't be
giving me suros regime you can't be
giving me duplicates so the problem is
not with the exotic proper eight I think
the issue is the duplication and I think
the issue is the sources I think that
you know if you do one part of the raid
maybe I can get a four second drop once
in a while you know I mean even just a
chance from like a red chest that used
to be the galley chest that's the carrot
like those little be like hey there's a
chance in here somebody good some exotic
you start to see some consistency out of
this just seems to have like maybe a
higher role he
I heard somebody even talk about the
whole skeleton keys and strike chess
that would be kind of amazing thing to
bring a whole different level just if
you're working on those pieces because
now I will say I haven't done that many
night falls but I did two of the Sabbath
and song last week I got to Duty bounds
in the same week now just literally be
are in Jesus shining way down on me but
I was like I hadn't seen that gun I
hadn't run night falls probably as much
as I used to but the fact they got to in
the same week and probably only ran like
three night falls I was like this is
weird guys some of those roles are there
and I'm I'm with you I'm torn on this
because I like exotics being rare
because one on one drop so huh what I
get and you honestly can't say you don't
have a forsaken exotic because you have
ace of spades so gotcha like the quest
exotics they don't I well I mean ace of
spades if you're not using that in PvP
you may as well just sit down understand
me I finally got my first piece of
exotic forsaken armor now I've had I
have a lot of duplicate weapons I've got
risk earner
I've got huckleberry I've got syrups
I've got what else have I seen I'm
trying to think I got one more I got
another graviton Lance yeah trying to
think how many and these are all
duplicates of stuff I already have so I
do understand the duplicates now as
infusion is expensive I've been okay
with them dropping caboose a little bit
of like okay fine there's a little bit
of infusion we're like fine I'll use
this because it's something I haven't
used in a little while graviton actually
doesn't have quite the same big appeal
as it used to by the way no I know I
know but I haven't had more drops than
you now I do like certain ones to where
they are tied to certain things and do
all every single wanted bounty you can
spin Simon's toilet or get those ghost
fragments do every single wanton bounty
if you want that Lord of wolves that's
where you get it that's where I like
there's there is a place it drops right
if you're gonna grind it out you've got
like 16 I don't even know
14:16 bounties that you can do you work
through all those and you don't get it
well damn that's I mean that's orangey
but that's you making literally content
for yourself because I'm trying to grind
out this weapon that's got it but it
does have a specific source as you're
talking about right fine
specific places where nightfall chest
might have a little higher drop so
that's even beat your head against it at
5:40 verse 540 and those nightfalls
heart make those a little bit higher
make one of the raid chests I mean we
have the exotic firm ribbon I actually
really like how that is set up
that's just a vex mythoclast was that
one's pretty cool and we're gonna have
these quests that work on but not all of
them are quests it's not just off and
some are are in G's
so the armor has been sparse like for
I've got more duplicate weapon drops but
for armor for Forsaken I have had
armamentarium
I got ashen Wake so those were my
duplicates but I finally this week
probably the past few days I got Ursa
for OSA oh good for you and I still know
that one gives the whole Sentinel shield
a whole new world because if you take a
buttload of damage you done with that
one you about three quarters back to
your super so I do like how the new
exotics can have some effect like we're
haven't seen a reviews on like the
coyotes path and double dodged ones you
just haven't seen reviews on because
like nobody but honestly for me that's
that carrot that's still out there where
I'm like I don't want them to tweak too
far back because this is where we we we
say this all the time don't give us too
much stuff too soon or it's gonna take
it all away or gonna take the desire to
want more of it away and that my big big
worry is because if they up that drop
right they make it too high too easy to
get our hands on it and then it's gonna
be like well I have all the exotics now
there's no point for me trying to do
these things this is what I'm gonna say
to that and I think you're gonna be okay
I think gonna be happy what I'm not
saying I think that we're gonna get into
what they're gonna do but based on
recent history right remember people
were complaining about escalation
protocol weapons not drop it right and
they will like you up we see what you're
talking about
we're gonna make an adjustment and it
was something like if you didn't have it
or you got one you know the entry each
time you failed the chance got more
you're in higher right yeah I gotta be
honest like since that happened I was
grinding you know I've been playing a
lot of escalation protocol to be honest
with you and uh yeah I got this sniper
but it took a while this is after
suppose an exotic incoming exotic but
the increase in drop rate yeah so I
still think they my gut when we get into
what they're gonna do is I still think
me and you as purists exotic purist I'll
call us that that's not new tactic that
tagline
I think we're gonna be okay eggshell
right exactly twenty surely policies
like I think we're gonna be okay
because escalation protocol I still
ain't got the sniper you know I'm saying
but um I mean it's give me the SMG I got
to spend when I got the SMG and I've
been planned in a while so these drop
rate it is not that big of a percentage
if you know I'm saying based on what
they're saying because I still haven't
gotten I play a lot so we'll see loosely
but let's get into what they're actually
yeah so their goals for exotic drop
rates are intended to be meaningful
long-term chases which I am okay with
finding the exact should be rare but
impactful problems are pattern exotic
right now we're failing short of the
impeccable part of our goal there's
nothing exhibiting your powerful diving
your fourth fighting light when all you
really want is a two-tailed Fox hey we
plan on increasing the chance for
exotics to drop something you don't
already have now they do say that not
gonna take away the chance for you get
duplicates is just saying they're going
to increase the chance for you know of
something newer so it's not gonna be
like a faded in gram of guarantee right
likely you're not gonna see ten old
exotics before you might see one new one
maybe it's like three before you see a
new one so if they don't overdo it too
much and again I like this is where some
of these communications are coming in
yes if they say hey we did we do want
them to be carrots Gjallarhorn was a
carrot for a damn year and that's what
made some of destiny's grind so great
yes it took me forever to get mine but
when I finally got it it was everybody's
hell yeah I mean there are videos
literally about those happen now as much
because half the time I feel like the
big hell yeah are either from quests
worst
one I don't know what the drop rate is
like for 1,000 voices but I feel like
I've seen enough out there that it's not
like as like you know Cornish as it
might have been but in general I'd like
to see I mean I'd like to see eight a
little baby buff and but I don't want to
see it too much because like me I've
probably had better orangey just cuz
I've had a decent amount of exotics drop
and I have gotten probably two or three
I got black talent though my first
exotic actually in all of the forsaken
was that damn sword black talent yeah
it's five ten and I have it infused it
and used it in forever I totally forgot
I still had the damn thing so generally
for me I probably been luckier than some
but I've also seen a whole lot of year
one exotics and while that may help
somebody who's newer coming in because
they're getting stuff they haven't seen
the people who have been around for a
while they're missing out on that so
tweaking it somewhat so you get some of
the newer ones even if they are rare
lean towards the newer ones if you've
got all the old ones that I'm okay with
right not like don't have let me start
sitting a checklist every lying a month
and then go a little bit yeah that was
the problem with d2 we we got the launch
of YouTube we got them all fairly fast
literally within the first two to three
weeks and you know two weeks it was just
like you know you start eventually with
swimming in them and um it just had no
wait no relevance and like you said it's
something to be said about you know
dudes we're making those galley videos
you know people just you like man I find
like I don't want that to things that I
want that on the wall like chest piece I
forget the name the Phoenix something I
think it's protocol it's protocol right
I want that so bad for my you know
saying I don't bleed the one that does
well and I really want the boots for the
warlock that extends chaos reach tops
that Dad I want more than anything cuz I
really want to run storm call right now
and there's a lot of issues with it I
mean with the chaos reach right now it
still bugged it I'm surprised I didn't
address it
in this thing and I'm gonna actually
reach out to them again about that mucho
op trials and reaching out to them about
on carries because there's not like
trial there that's that's in a in a dark
corner somewhere nothing is not being
worked on but that
right corners but I am upset that all
these new supers came out one is clearly
not working as intended they barely
mentioned that it had an issue they
didn't officially put it on a 12-day
right now all right here's the problem
with the chaos reach super is you jump
in there you come handy huh Dragon Ball
Z thing can't stop it I know right yes
well yeah you're supposed to stop that
so let's say I kill one person I can
stop it at 80 percent at the moment of
stopping my super is supposed to be at
80 percent yeah now it's back to zero
that is a problem it's not working isn't
that supposed to be the strength and
then even like that's why they got those
boots call topping off because they
figured people were gonna do that and
then you run around you run around and
you start to speed up to get your super
against to up it makes it so effective
in theory that he would have your super
a lot if you're conservative about it
and I want that in the worst way but the
super is not working as intended I'm not
playing it and I'm just not because as
it is right now I stay in the air let's
say I miss my target or I kill one guy
I'm still in the air shooting the whole
super off at nobody and a sitting duck
for someone to just come from the side
or behind it so yeah get about kill oh
so that's a problem so you know they've
got it they got address that but back to
the whole point with the whole exotic
things yeah I'm which you they still
need to be exotic I think this is a step
in the right direction you know and
basically they they upping the faded
Engram orangey so to speak right yeah
it's not quite a checklist but you're
leaning towards leaning towards starting
to work your way through some of the
newer stuff right which yeah I was like
I just don't wanna see them throw I
don't want to go all the way to d2 but
it's like everybody's like some are like
I'm played like 14,000 hours and I've
got like one and there's there needs to
be a little bit of a balance but I do
like the carrot still being out there so
we'll see how they tweak it and stuff
but I kind of I kind of like how they're
like they're gonna increase the chance
they're like we're not going to
checklist I would've been like ah crap
yeah we're going to increase the chance
then you know that's little exotics are
meant to be that way so like just
because d2 had you built up in this idea
that we got them all the time
if you played d1 welcome back to it but
I wasn't hard grind so so Mac mmm
agreed iron banner whoo
it came through whoa how much did you
play do you knock out all your eyes
everything Kalyn blaze I had so much fun
and I said check out my Twitter man I
was out here I was out here it was bad
for people I was doing things to me man
they they were like it was me I had so
much fun
shout out to the clan Iowa caucus clan
we definitely wrecked shot I mean we
were mercy it was bad but now seriously
it was it was fun it felt so good for
power battery good um you know it was
just one of those things that to be
honest besides the power back the real
thing and I don't think gets enough
credit and I really loved it and I
almost it's so good that I almost can't
play control the normal way anymore like
yeah I know what you mean yeah that was
a small tweak to control in iron man
should be all the time that locked
mechanic when your dog starts howling
yeah wolf dog you got do you hear that
and it's just like will I get them
because we know you get those kills and
you know kill quite bonus and you
locking things down it really
incentivize aggression cuz normally
before you would say hey don't cap the
third because the spawns are gonna flip
right now it's like no you capped that
third minute you can't get a chance and
you do that and you really can start and
start like crushing people but here's
the other thing I've been on the
opposite where I've been getting stumped
and that's my general cuz I don't play
with teams that often yeah see because
the thing is what I'll be honest what
out seems it's has been brutal for a
while I mean that's general it is brutal
as a solo player it is very you have to
be very lucky as well as the only
chances I've had is when I really like
held it down KD was like in the tombs or
something you know and higher and just
really played above my weight
and then okay I got my team in position
and then what saved me would be like
okay
a clutch power play towards the end of a
match yeah and then it's all we got and
we turn it in time and that's why I just
love that McKenna at least it gives some
hope for comeback but yeah eventually
they may have to think about doing
something you know with the solo guys
cuz it is rough it is very rough as I
was like that's one of the things that
like so many people have argued about
now I know this is hole meant to be
played as a team and this is like one of
those that goes back and forth and some
of the elite players are just like fine
team play at lfv it I don't know me like
I see matches where they are completely
right you'll see like 12 different clan
names on there the initials there so
they do exist I know that people are out
there and honestly sometimes the wait
for crucible are long enough I have to
wait like an extra couple I'd wait like
an extra minute or so in a solo queue
yeah it's guaranteed that everybody was
that way cuz I do think that would level
the playing field right I don't know if
they will ever do that because they've
people have been asking for that crap
forever so it was like as iron banner is
hard enough with the team because power
level matters and if you're playing a
team of six I guarantee you those people
probably work together and played a
little more than your random group that
you paired up with and while you may be
decent if you're five seven and you
paired up with two people they're like 5
funny and they're just getting stepped
on all the time you're at a disadvantage
straight up row between the team shot
again the other I wish there was more of
a an occasional sotol queue or just
better matchmaking to be like hey if
there's three on this team find a group
of three and then randomize the others
at least equate the team's whether it's
solo matchmaking or not just equate the
teams I've seen overwatch do it from the
very beginning yes that crap has to
exist they're dedicated probably so yeah
and there are definitely times where
it's like that's the whole thing even on
PC is like I don't feel it as bad
sometimes as they used to one console
just consoles can't process stuff is
faster but there are definitely times
when I'm playing on piece or I feel like
man I'm on fire I'm hitting my shots I
feel like I'm accurate and then you get
the flip where your side's not the host
and you are screwed mm your sight like
with you're not the host like people are
a little bit more warp EP shots aren't
quite landing as much I'm like
just got done playing the same game same
guns and I feel like I'm a different
skill level in the following game just
cuz I'm like different people I'm like I
know sometimes the matchmaking some
people may be better or worse but I feel
like my shots land sometimes and then
they don't on others and I can watch
people like be like hey everything looks
money on my side then the other time
people are warping and jumping around so
it's like some of those things like I
still can't quite figure out how the
whole hybrid matchmaking hasn't ever
gotten to dedicated servers but you know
it's only four years and what are you
gonna do yeah shut up the TF Chronos
gambit same thing full team's full teams
duo solos like hair the matches if there
are two and to match the two in twos in
gambit even more by the way on the
gambit just because it's so objective
base no I just say that's another reason
for cross progression for the future to
increase those play a bases if they
worried about counts being low imagine
if you had all systems in one queue hard
like you'd be good when to go play on
xbox borealis doesn't work with if it
was really great a damn thing that's not
that hard
yeah no I mean transferring data between
all the others like I mean no I can look
on my bunch account but it should just
be your Bungie login you log in this is
your stuff exactly as I can see it
everywhere on dim just and I can see it
I can literally see it on the bungee
happy shows B oh look at these guys in
our own pleasure oh look at this guys I
don't clean up for it you know an Xbox
it does it this so the functionality is
just literally they have to implement it
and hopefully by d3 you can finally get
that put that to rest happy us because
we gotta play together like I'm not
gonna go box I'm potentially going to
brand get a brand new who's gonna get a
computer therefore you're the one who's
gonna be able to play I will buy you
destiny on PC when you straight-up
sold incognito I will buy it for him
when that computer is built and then
well then he I'm sorry guys on Xbox you
won't see me again he respects the nice
stuff when I know the uncle boards might
be there on the Xbox
so you're gonna be like sorry guys it's
pretty can't go back anyway so iron
banner there were ups and downs I know
some of the bounties were definitely a
grind you know and that was the only
thing about the iron banner bounties as
there's so much other stuff to do it is
hard to spend time in that much in iron
banner going for like you know 15 power
play kills which you might give zero for
like three or four matches then you
might get one and you might get three
you don't quite know in person I mean a
lot there were just a lengthy grinds
they are going to know there's two
pieces of this and if you guys heard
dados video he was like hey I am banner
it's not quite as easy and they're gonna
give away they're not gonna give away
stuff well guess what next iron banner
thanks for changing so yeah
bow knees most of them pretty much all
the girls have been shortened orbs has
been cut and a half match completions is
down in half which is insane
super kills been cut by five certain
ones have been lowered and each one of
the bounties that there were for the
granted legendary which was the lower
gear and two were powerful which is
probably that smaller tier like one or
two above once you get above 540 all of
these are gonna be powerful gear now
every single bounty yeah thing what do
you what do you think
listen I'm caught it I mean like you
said there's so much things to do right
now so you've got it incentivize that
dad I think that's the key word today
incentivize you have to incentivize
activities if you want people to stay in
this activity then you gotta get
powerful gear and we all know in
forsaken how people react when they see
powerful gear on the screen you got
included so I'm cool this this is fine
you know and in all and I gotta defend
myself to like I've got grind I really
did crying I abandon doing and still was
trying to do everything like I basically
no life state when I am ban it came out
and I still didn't get I got all the
powerful gear which was like the two or
three of those bounties they were only
giving it but um yeah I didn't get
everything done I got the precision
kills I forgot what it was it was like
maybe one or two bang and I was like you
know it ain't giving power forget I'm
good I got everything I want hit and I'm
out you know I'm saying so yeah I like
this I like that the whole thought
process of it that's how I managed to be
which was to you know get it gave I
remember a lot of people in my clan
lower light and I'm like dude get in the
iron banner now yeah it is mostly I mean
match wins I mean if you're playing with
randoms yeah it's gonna be a little
tougher but eventually you'll probably
knock him out hopefully yeah I mean
super kills those are ones just use your
super that's literally why it's all that
stuff I mean but there's some there's
still skill precision kills orbs things
I mean there's certain ones that are
gonna be spend some time there's a
couple that are gonna be skill level
that you're gonna have to work on but
overall I mean I'm okay with it
generally because I think this is gonna
be more along the lines of there's three
different tiers of powerful gear and I
still think this is gonna be tier one
all right yeah I mean I'm in the middle
with all of them being powerful yeah I
don't know how I feel about all of them
so I'm a little data we on that one but
you know it does come around you know
it's a thing I'm just I'm just concerned
that everybody's just gonna okay boom
max why here we go again but you don't
we'll see we see I be I do I do feel
something had to be done I would have
been cool honestly just three yet I'm
saying I believe like the old rise of
irons to have like three meaningful
traps from either the bounties or
whatever from settled into something you
know if I recall correctly but um yeah I
think would have been a sweet spot but I
guess they say hey you know we want to
put it out so I just we gotta see how it
goes how easy and how fast it is or
whatever whatever but something did have
to get done the ground was pretty
intense and all these other things in
activities that forsaken has you know to
dedicate that amount to just this for
only you know who to not fear yeah so I
mean a little bit more than me I don't
think it's gonna be the big jumps
they're not gonna be dreaming city level
of gems and light level but especially
if you're gonna spend some time in iron
banner and it's gonna help you can I
like level out your gear bump them up
here in their little places you know
that's fine I mean the grind is long
enough as it is if it's just one more
you're still gonna have to spend some
time they're not like easy but I mean
kills us from 250 dunno 150 precision
kills 100 250 like some of those took
some hits but I mean they're still not
gonna be ones like precision kills 50 if
precision is not your game that's not
gonna take a minute so but I know if
precision is what I'm going for I'm
definitely gonna be changing up my
scout rifles snipers actually like I was
working on the precision skills I was
like screw this I kept seeing Pantheon
or what does it know control Virgil yeah
I was like all right here come some
Snipes walk down that hallway wait from
and I had my dreaded venture just
started popping heads so I missed that
map because it literally is one where
the sniper lanes are very very obvious
and I can actually just practice my
sniping more on that one and I'm not
gonna say I'm amazing but it's a way for
me to actually work on the skill a
little because they're very obvious
lanes for that so listen I'm not a
sniper I had dread for it but I'm happy
that it's back because you guys knew
Scott in your chat yeah I think it's
great for Arianna to have old apologize
but I also think if that's the case the
bounty should take long to do if
achievable yeah it's still a hard task
for end gear guys what do you think
about us so I would be honestly okay
with that like some of them were longer
for sure so even if they hadn't touched
the bounties just made them all powerful
that would still be more incentive just
to spend time in there and naturally
work on things yeah man I should be long
so you're saying bounty should be longer
but they should change the bounty says
something different when is available
this past iron banner yeah I was like I
don't want them to always be the same
bounties bounties cannot be that hard to
program and to me at least in theory
there's probably enough stuff that they
track and things like that I don't want
to see the same six bounties for every
iron banner because then it just tends
to get a little old what if it's like
okay what about the ones that used to be
like hey Auto rifle kills for crucible
things like that have a reason to play
differently maybe one or two maybe one
daily bounty the mixes things up a
little bit so you see different loadouts
different guns in there as opposed to
Precision's and orbs and stuff like that
mix it up just a little bit so but I'm
honestly okay with the bounties being a
decent amount of a grind because even if
you didn't finish them all but say I've
finished four and they were all powerful
then I think it would probably still be
okay because as you said you didn't get
everything done you got four done but
after a while you're like the last two
didn't have powerful you might have
spent a little more time and you
basically know life that you said you
basically no life the damn game for a
weekend you didn't finish them all so I
mean they are not small grinds some are
gonna come quicker than others wins but
to me yeah I'd like to
and this is the whole I don't want to
see everything get casualized I don't
want to see these bounties keep dropping
and eating or any so it's like they
gotta watch how easy they make some
things so II have Scott I probably said
that run the first time I thought was oh
my
oMG it's cool but it's um do you Scott
yeah I was like I like the grind still
being out there it just worried about
things getting too easy and I know that
some people want but you got to work for
what you got so yeah I got a good point
um in case you guys are wondering how
power level works they put a nice actual
chart out there so 10 power level is
actually a pretty quick drop so I mean
those first so even like ten power
levels when you're up at 590 or 600 it's
still gonna make a difference when you
start to max out a little bit if you're
not using that optimal gear in soar that
infusion piece is kind of a factor
you'll notice they make a very hard kind
of point right here at a hundred power
level difference you're doing 20% damage
less or 20% damage more and then if you
all the way get down to 200 power levels
if somebody's jumping into iron banner
but they only have like expansion to not
300 they're gonna be on the struggle bus
cuz they're doing 50% damage and it's
gonna be rough now seriously I'm kind of
curious what are your thoughts on that
one because I know it's only oh you know
it's a one-week thing it's not up all
the time
but for those who do want to play iron
banner it's a chance they get here those
who jump in and want to try and like
level up mm-hmm the grinds harder it is
not yeah it is I mean I'm gonna sound so
elitist but thing is that's what the
mode is about it's in the lore the
strongest Guardians you know I'm saying
put themselves to the test this is not
regular this is not shacks is crucible
you know saying so you know listen
you're gonna get drops you're gonna get
kills especially now with the boundaries
being tweaked away they're gonna be
tweaked to make it easier you know I'm
saying and here's the other thing I'm at
a lower light I used to be first of all
let me not meet myself some credit as
I'm sounding very elitist right now but
when I used to play mana back in the day
right these guys were always ahead of me
sinister a gaming addict all
guys were always ahead of me like level
watch those are the light level chasers
in my clan my thing is I'll get to it
when I get to it right so when I amana
came around I made it my business to
stay in packs I didn't go off on too
much missions by myself because
literally I wasn't strong enough to be
able to you know take a lot of the
one-on-ones or if I didn't have like the
God role weapon at the time so you just
got a play smarter you got to say okay
you know what I know him it's the same
mentality when I went when I went to the
lighthouse and trials I wasn't maxillae
that wasn't these guys will highlight to
me but I played smart I played more
defenses I played in packs you have to
change the way you think it's the same
attention to detail the mentality I was
saying with um gambit when people were
complaining about the sleeper not saying
the sleeper is not ridiculous but I'm
just saying that ya know when you hear
room invader you have to play a certain
different way now yeah and that's all
I'm saying so again I am happy this is
back yeah you're not gonna get a
contradictory out of realism leave it
the way it is if you want to be strong
go get strong go hit the gym go hit the
gym get that light up hit the weights
you know I'm saying these things for you
to do if you still don't feel
comfortable stepping in that arena but
this is the big boy arena if you don't
want you wanna do you got crucible over
here for you you got breakthrough and
all this other stuff for you if you want
to come in here just prepare to grind
and play smart you will get the gear you
will get drops you'll get killed she's
not like you're not gonna kill nobody
you can get cleanup kills you can do a
whole bunch of things it's not
impossible do not bring it back to pre
uh uh you know iron banner d2 wait
didn't even matter
like I love where it is right now I
think Iron Man is in a fantastic place
me personally I mean you're not gonna
get a whole bunch argument out of me I
mean I know there are people out there
who are still playing force a can be an
art playing destiny and without forsaken
right that's gonna be a pretty big
difference because they're capping in
about 380 so you're gonna see that two
hundred power level difference right
mm-hm and I know it's not an option no
I'm just trying to think of the way to
phrase this I know not everybody can buy
everybody expansion I'm lucky enough to
be able to do that and I'm thankful for
that but if you're playing iron banner
against people who it does matter and
they're up to date with the game and
they just have access to higher level
and content quick play as you said quick
plays your thing it doesn't matter in
there iron banner is one of those that
comes up once a month whatever their
rotations gonna be and it's a chance for
that to matter it's a chance for that
person at 600 who has more 600 gear
options maybe got that gun to your role
maybe they've got a little bit more
infusion and things are gonna matter so
I mean yeah we're gonna sound kind of
like you know a little elitist right now
and I'm not even next level I got my the
floor just mop with my it's all over it
a few times and then there were other
times where I could they'll be like they
didn't have a chance against me because
I might have been trading a 520 and I
was 540 sorry it went both ways and
probably will for a little while as we
all work on levelling up this will
probably be a less of a factor for most
of us right then those are like 600 to
to like 600 a 380 if I see a 380 and
they're like I'm sorry but I was like
when I've gone through enough solo
queues and iron banner it basically
feels like I'm 200 powers under level
anyway yeah that's just kind of how that
one's gonna roll it's a way just to give
Iron Man or something different and a
way to set it apart I can't repeat like
we're gonna go ahead and leave that
there so but did you explain it pretty
clearly so I mean just read the chart as
is but say if I'm 100 power level below
my opponent I'm doing 80% damage but if
you're hundred power levels over your
opponent you're doing 20% more damage
it's a smaller curve I mean right here
at the beginning if you're about ten
levels and this is where equipping your
highest stuff for iron banner is gonna
make a difference
10 present damage on some of those
little crucial kills resilience and all
those pieces will add up to winning and
losing battles right but you know though
I love that no absolutely and that's one
of it maxing your character or playing
if your stuff is gonna be the factor and
that's why I was like
hey you didn't few this infuse this up
well maybe you get two and hopefully
with this initiative being more frequent
or whatever cores are gonna be then
it'll be reasonable because right now
that's the other problem that
exacerbated it works I'm not gonna spend
my cores for one weekly activity but it
sucks that I can't jump up in level all
the things that I want to play with just
so I am the highest levels that's again
nothing banner was one of those things
that pointed out even more the course
were an issue so no absolutely you
definitely right with that because I had
that decision I had I got in my opinion
a God for all go go figure
Michaels figure man let me tell you I'm
right I'm doing um I think it's got a
handling mod in it but the role is full
auto and it sounds basic it's full auto
and moving target so you were like okay
first of all for full auto takes that
gun to another level
yeah okay moving target in gunfights
while they strafing while you're
strengthened and that gun staying sticky
and then on top of it I do on the
default tier model does for gun model
tailing but then I bought a banshee
um target acquisition mark nice it's
disgusting so it's just like I'm sitting
in on my yo I gotta bring my baby
forward so there goes those course like
you said you know cuz I had to make the
decision but yeah it's just one of them
things man I do like the fact though
that i sat there to my entire armory and
my weapons and said okay what's giving
me max like and also in conjunction with
you know trying sometimes I sacrifice
like I was like look this one's giving
me more shotgun rounds per scavenge per
green block scavenge my light goes down
about two but that's a killer perk I
rather have that with the lower light so
that when I'm picking up shotgun those
green blocks off the floor my shotguns
rock and my eye closes rockin you said
I'm saying so again I'm eight I didn't
go into panel with my max like I likes
do whatever most
my best loadout and I'm saying and you
still be effective you have the best
loadout you can still work now yet light
is an advantage no doubt names I'm not
gonna I'm not belittling that but this
still ways around it and play smart work
with teams
you're gonna unlock stuff you're gonna
get bound he's done your event get
powerful gear especially with this next
iron band all the way they're tweaking
it and you're gonna be okay yep nope I
agree I mean that's just one of those
pieces where it makes you think a little
more and sometimes it's good for a game
to do that
so an argue with that one if you guys do
want to see some amazing art between
Bungie high Moon Studios and forgetting
the third one Vicarious Visions
all those guys have done some amazing
stuff if you guys haven't played the
corrupted strike haven't seen some of
the Dreaming city like all of this stuff
is beautiful raisi town
check out these artists check out their
basically they'll have their it's art
station it'll be their page browse
through their pictures some of these
renderings they do are gonna be much
higher quality than we're ever gonna get
even I will get anything and this stuff
looks amazing so this girl through here
look at this I mean this is from the
mission opening section you've got the
reef just these high crispy images are
so nice to look at so shoutouts are the
artist guys there's a lot of really cool
ones in here just looking at the detail
on some of the stuff that's like the
most high def mo brick you'll probably
ever see for example this one right here
so it's just a detail and stuff you guys
get in some of these as they render them
out they're really cool so shout outs of
the artists just scrolling through these
real quick this is a really really tall
image mm-hmm this one right here but I
know it's like a hallway from prison
anything is probably crazy huge but that
shot right there of that abomination is
just a detail you don't get to see
normally it's nice because we're always
usually shooting from farther away just
the little details get to see up close
the chains are on their wrists the way
the face is actually completely covered
in the mask
it's crazy so just and then this is I
think I don't know if this is the final
raid boss or not or I wonder if this is
the one from a shattered throne I'm
trying to remember now that is
because I was like there's no like could
be a Sabbath oh yeah remember I can't
remember the name of like the shadow
throne boss I've seen the name but I
think it was like a wizard but kind of
an interesting one so I mean this is
like wizard to like level 10 so evil but
I mean that's kind of these are some of
the cool things we get to see you behind
the scenes and these are just fun for
them to throw out occasionally they have
a little thing going on so they're
working on the Bungie holiday card and a
couple different options so if you're an
artist out there and submit your stuff
and these are just some that they've
done before this one's actually pretty
cute
get out larry's I love that and this
one's just crispy just a clean little
bungee in the corner just snowflake and
then just the trample hanging from a
tree and again sometimes simple works in
art shout-out by the way to everybody in
chat if you guys are an artist out there
I wanted to say I've got quite a few
requests for this thing to go on audio
so to get it on either pod bean or
iTunes and you got to go through a whole
process to get iTunes approved but for
you guys just to have a way to listen to
the audios I know people have asked so I
do want to try and work on that if you
guys are an artist and want to make us a
little flash point logo I would be
appreciative oh that's please I mean it
doesn't even have to be like crazy right
now but if you want to whip something up
just so we can slap something on there
there's some details about it and stuff
but if you'll reach out let me know you
can send me a message on YouTube I try
and check most all those or hit me on
Twitter just be cool to work on give you
guys just the flash point audio version
for those of you that don't catch this
live or want to watch it on YouTube you
can definitely catch it on just more of
a audio stream so if you're walking your
dog or just you know listen to a podcast
you can do it that way so random
shout-out to the artist out there in the
world yeah if you got some if you feel
like helping you know we'd be
appreciative mmm
peace out there and everyone to be jump
into because this is good question I
didn't know I think we you know kind of
get to that point but you know same
thing I'm I saw guys you know if you you
guys you know I know the boss is doing
it if you guys really want me to push
please leave in the comments after the
video if you watch it late you know hey
I really want you know to appreciate us
doing audio for it you know jump on that
train - I mean I can do
wit now see we started small we're
slowly growing but if the request is
there the man is there I will definitely
do it as well so please if you want it
please let me know and we definitely
trying to listen you guys and take your
guys feedback as we you know try to grow
this thing and definitely like you say
like logo is definitely next we
definitely were trying to work on that
so all you aspiring artists if you have
any ideas hey feel free oh yeah those
are cool submit them you might get you
know your emblem and stuff like that as
for a bunch of player support you know
just basic stuff they talk about some
maintenance some known issues things
like that that they're working on I
won't cover all of those there's been
some issues with this week's Spyder
bounty prime engrams for crucible
randomly not dropping just different
things certainly not working so
definitely check out bungie.net for
their pardon our dust they are working
on stuff no games perfect so they are
working on it but at least they say hey
these are known so do what you came to
avoid it if it have my stupid OE I'm
upset I'm just saying it's gonna happen
with supers at some point whether it's
balancing whether it's like bring in
some of the other classes so they're a
little more synergistic with their
classes stuff like that I mean changes
that are gonna have to happen at some
point so we'll see if that comes in a
big sweeping past maybe in December
shout out to both esoteric and I think
it was Slayer age who both have like
slow low full solo flawless the
shattered throne that's a hell of a feat
I mean granted they're like maybe five
ninety six hundred so I mean they're
doing it at the right light level to do
it but either way to solo this thing
when they're just trying to figure that
stuff out that was up quick so those are
crazy
dreaming city little random video and
more Bungie bounties will continue so if
you're looking to try and take on some
people look at your platform look at
your time see if you'll be awakened
around yes sir and that does pretty much
wrap up the tois I'll just leave you
guys a crazy picture for now so you can
look at something yeah if you got a
minute I did want to ask you one more
thing
sure or in the economy world mods mmm
very interesting what you those like my
biggest thing right now
is I had a bunch of I had a whole bunch
of parts to break down now I've been
buying little bits and pieces here and
there I like to make sure I have like
one of each mod but I haven't like
hardly modded any armor yet um I've been
buying the mods but I mean I know I
could buy the mods cuz I broke down and
I have like you know I had 230 mod
components Jesus oh yeah I mean I bought
some here and then I kept breaking down
weapons so I've got a few more but if
again this is kind of the question of
for economies right for a new person for
a place to get mods yeah they have no
way to earn mod components ban she
doesn't I have 5,000 gunsmith materials
I can't do squat with yeah that's
frustrating yeah
sucks and actors in the gun - yeah
you're right absolutely yeah so I mean
the ones you get random components on
maybe you have dropped like I've played
a decent amount and they're probably
some sporadic ones with mods out there
but generally just uh where do you think
the mod economy should go do you think
it's in a good spot bad spot just
thoughts on that yeah that's a good
point a good question um yet easily
fixed I think that um I think the
mistake they may hit is just assuming
everyone's coming from the old d2
expansions into this you know and
bringing all their huge you know gear in
that's why I think they they they
changed banshees arm economy rate it
takes way more leveling now if you
notice so I think that was done to
throttle ask the hardcore again I get it
for the hardcore but like you said for
the part of the guy who's just starting
forsaken doesn't have master what course
doesn't have you know I'm saying my
components he's not getting any of those
things banshee selling and I'm saying no
again it's it's not skewed correctly it
has to be changed now I'm on the
opposite spectrum I have been using mods
um I think the mods themselves are
really good I've tested I believe want
to give the correct person credit Oh
somebody's got a video out right now
away breaking down I think one of the
major
in minor that type of thing everything
go one some people are going I think one
of them is cool guy oh yeah yeah can't
remember the name but shout out to who
did it not quite the honor here exactly
shouts are those guys and I'm telling
you right now if you're running double
or triple super regeneration mine's
really makes a difference I've seen it
so I've been doing that but again with
infusion the way it is I have to be very
judicious about what I'm putting it in
because I don't want to I be the mistake
and I put it in something I liked and
I'm like yeah and then boom I'm getting
higher light level stuff in that
category and now there goes wasted mod
and I don't want to break that thing
down to get the mod back because it's
you know I'm saying it was kind of like
a good roll so it dish still has to be
tweeted still has to be fixed as far as
getting components and let's give again
Banksy a little bit more functionality
with stuff like that so that they had
the right idea with the mod and how
they're doing it but it's not
implemented correctly no you got to be
able to earn them yes I agree I agree
but the mods a good man I've tried the
ones I've tested his boss back I've
gotten a hand cannon with triple tap oh
so good I got it I got a ten paces with
that so nasty I got like I told you
about my Goldfinger with the unarmed
aim-assist so nasty the super Mars I got
those the you know Paragon stuff where I
can get my um basically I roll I put
that inside my Luna faction boots so
this way you know boom I'm getting the
riff faster to get empowering rift feels
good feels strong um I had hip fire but
I didn't really I couldn't think of any
only thing I could think of was like
maybe that would be good in a grenade
launcher but I was like I'm not really
firing a bunch of things yeah that was
there's a couple that I've been kind of
Warner and we talked about this a little
bit last week because you've got hip
fires a big one I'm not gonna throw that
on next yeah basically what am I gonna
hit fire like that's what I was thinking
I I literally tried I got two of them
and I was like I'm starting one
I'm like I'm not really shooting from
the hip we go on no I want to be
accurate pretty much I mean yeah as you
said grenade launcher literally might be
the only one it just says increase
accuracy and ready speed while firing
from the hip and maybe this literally
just what it's meant for is a grenade
launcher but there's not many uses for
that one another one we were talking
about was the minor enemies so the minor
spec deals extra damage to the
rank-and-file enemies like where and we
were literally trying to figure this out
last week where does that fit cuz boss
like most enemies to that level whether
it's wrong I mean now Knights can
technically be red bars yeah I mean
there are points where sometimes if you
know you have a whole bunch of Reds but
typically when you're gonna want mods
it's for the higher level stuff you're
going to see majors you're gonna see
more bosses those are where you're gonna
want that extra damage because those mid
tiers hopefully you can deal with them
otherwise you know Oh another
methodology but generally that's kind of
the ones that yeah I guess a little bit
for me because some of those are more
and there seemed to be some more mods
out there that we haven't quite seen the
whole take and repurposing destroying a
takin shield room brushes your grenade a
build like I think I got one of those
from doing I don't even know where the
hell that one came from and I think a
buddy of mine got one too that was
literally just like from doing something
specific so there's a few that we
haven't seen so as you said I like the
concept of these it's just like
sometimes the accessibility to get them
or again that decision to use it is
almost so detrimental for somebody new
that they're almost gonna be afraid to
or if they do then they're stuck with
something that's unfortunately not the
greatest role so it's just a tweak of
like again Banshee couple these vendors
just need a little more to do I'll do a
serve video in an hour and a half and
I'm not even sure there's much of a
function to it okay right
if you ou know where he is mostly it's
just the location and if you want some
new roles on some armor that's not gonna
be like 380 but you want an exotic at
least that's like 520 and maybe there
are some good rules it is weird Hauser's
roles if it's helmets they all seem to
have the same mod for the week if
they're if it's like the same piece like
two helmets like for a Titan and a
warlock they're gonna have the exact
same model
Zach lick weird I've seen that multiple
weeks now so that's an odd thing but
generally I mean they make the made the
mods more meaningful their general use
which is cool I think it's just kind of
tweaking a couple pieces here and there
but yeah yeah I think that's kind of our
biggest thing and that was kind of one
of the topics I wanted to cover today
it's like Korres needs weeks we need a
way to earn them mods need tweaks we
need ways to earn them
we just need ways to make those thievin
if it's just randomly from chests
occasionally I open like a hundred chest
on the dreaming city I probably might
have like maybe I get like five course
from doing that just occasionally have
those things be throughout the world or
have bounties and ways to I don't want
yes six thousand down is because I'd
like I just knew other places yeah
addict says he misses strange coins can
of worms I don't like that's just one
more of those pain that was just one of
those things everybody farmed I haven't
forget how you got those damn things
like all those pieces then you
accumulated so many you could buy
everything I mean charges in the same
position they are I have three thousand
shards so what are you gonna do but
about anything
yeah it's just shards twenty three or
twenty nine shards depending on if it's
a weapon or armor and then the big ones
ninety seven the faded well he still
sell but the fade again but all old the
only thing I would say is if you're on
xbox or pc hit that faded if you don't
have borealis yet that is true I don't
have borealis but I mean if you got
three thousand shards spending ninety
seven probably not a terrible idea but
outside of that attic attic says or
feels less relevant because he doesn't
have his own currency III here we go
daddy I think what kind of touched on is
early I think he just needs to give half
bounties if masterwork cores or whatever
this new thing is so important give him
some bounties for that you know I'm
saying or have him exchange shards for
arm what you call it um you know four
cores or something like maybe have that
kind of like a another spider you know
I'm saying so to speak in the interim
we'll see without their ridiculous
raising the prices yeah the inflation
exactly oh yeah I think that's probably
most of it for the day I know you gotta
try and find some way to hey they're
kind of which crime sub thank you
certified what's up what's up I knew you
were catching the tail into this thing
so sorry to get the sub and bail on you
but for the support I do appreciate that
big time yes thank you thank you for the
support I know on YouTube if you guys
found me there thank you guys for coming
over and checking this thing out we do
our ridiculous long points flash is
probably the wrong word I got that
thumbnail too long point to the flash
point is kind of the idea but I've got
some new people and twitch chat this
morning so thank you guys
oMG I certified shout out to him in chat
yeah we'll post this thing up on YouTube
I'll probably do it tomorrow but I think
that well if I could probably talk to
you guys here off enough for the day so
I probably should wrap it up we are over
2 to 13 cells uh oh yeah you want to
wrap your site up I'm gonna hit mine go
for it man good to be back in the biz
talking flashpoint talking destiny my
brethren really good to do so um yeah
man this is good obviously you know
where to find me on Twitter at Lord
Cognito and obviously you can file also
the aisle or podcast at iron Lord with a
digital single note s on the Twitter
account I am Lord podcast please follow
us there um this Sunday got a nice guest
it will be on Rick Hogue from Hogue law
so we're gonna get if you want to get
the background on how games
contractually things get made and you
know intellectual property as well as
all the juicy tidbits with the tale
telltale closing and lawsuits you know
this guy's really good man he's a gamer
as well you know we're really gonna get
a chance to dive deep into some subjects
or if you're interested in that every
Sunday is the Lord's Day 11:00 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time that will be on
the inner circle network so please join
the live chat there and of course on the
iron Lords podcast YouTube channel you
have a flash point you have combat talk
you have
I was going to eat three packs all the
shows all that good stuff getting
reviews up I want to shout out our
stream team son although he's gonna have
a review up we're doing the game scum I
believe a review coming up very soon so
look out for that we definitely try to
get games a little earlier
give us our perspective we're working on
things and hopefully get a box to sit on
down with the string D that'd be good
maybe screws up for us that we could
that's that may be any works late but
yeah man catches as much we can really
trying to put out good content and yeah
man there's a good flash point chess was
fantastic great to see you guys great to
be talking destiny and being all engaged
so that's what I got
yeah so I mean I'll wrap up as well
first shout out to about 4,000 new
people which just blows my mind well
seriously like I'll go check my
analytics and I literally have like 40 I
think it's 4,600 new subscribers in the
past like week I don't I don't even know
what to say to that to all of you guys
and gals out there I say mostly guys but
any ladies out there welcome as well
believe me I'm beside myself and kind of
what's happened biggest one out there
but I mean I think you guys huge yeah so
we'll see what this weekend does
probably gonna be working on a heroic
guide as well not gonna see 190,000
views out of it but definitely some
people are asking so try and get a new a
fresh or get out there but yeah you guys
can find me on Twitter as well it's Eve
on ttis everywhere so if you search
Yvonne juice you'll find me I
technically have an Instagram but I
don't use it I'll work on that some
point but I just please keep it up with
all of these things is plenty but
generally guys that's been awesome loved
and forsaken we know it's not perfect
economies need tweet if you haven't made
it to the raid just know it's gonna be
waiting for you when you get ready keep
grinding and if you get tired of the
grind for a little bit spend some time
play spider-man come back when you're
ready
I say spider-man just cuz it was a big
one that came out recently whatever's
coming I mean college redo blackouts
gonna be one that pulls some people away
for a little bit I don't even know if I
care about multiplayer just blackout
because it's a polished battle royale
could be fun way just to you know
discharged in time and you have a little
fun in there but generally guys it's
been amazing
I'll keep the content coming to you guys
be a flashpoint we'll post it
I will see what I can do and I know you
were talking about the audio but I mean
I can see about doing it for both of us
really cuz you already have one podcast
so good happy great to see what that
yeah I'll just see what I can do for
figuring that one out just so there's an
audio source for both side for you guys
to listen whether it's not from iron
Lords are from my youtube just so you
guys can actually see it all but other
than that guys thank you very much I
think we will wrap it up here so the
vampire can get some sleep and then
other than that guys we will see you
next week check out our videos check out
iron Lords podcast on Sunday those guys
are awesome if nothing else try and
catch them live or at least the intros
the man of intros man who was listened
to recently I've been trying to catch up
on a few that I missed and they're just
like dude you should be doing those
intros for somebody because it's me
every time they're so good so appreciate
what you have a lot the master yeah so
you guys have been awesome thank you
very much and we will see hopefully more
of you next week spread the word and if
you can watch this on your phone or your
computer or wherever you're at we'll see
y'all soon